SENATE GOVERNMENTAL IN
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE --
TO ORDER --
WE HAVE SEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA OF WHICH NONE OF THE
ITEMS ARE ON CONSENT --
ONCE WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHICH
IS THE ITEM NUMBER NINE WILL
ADOPT OUR 200-019-2000 --
TWENTY COMMITTEE RULES.
SO WITH THAT.
LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS THAT THAT THE
COMMITTEE RULES BE ADOPTED. FOR
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A QUORUM.
YOU KNOW KALRA.
HERE WE GO.
FIRST MEETING DOT.
YOUR DOT HERE WILK PRESIDENT
WILL CARE [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCH LETTER HERE BARGES. FOR
JUST HERE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE CHIANG
[inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HELLO.
HELLO HERE WEST SO.
WEST OF HERE JOHNS.
NELSON NELSON HERE PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO HERE RUBIO
[inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WINNER HERE [inaudible]
OKAY.
NOW LET'S DO --
I MOVED SET UP THE RULES.
MOTION IS THAT THE COMMITTEE
RULES BE ADOPTED DOT.
HI DODD AYE WILK HI WILK AYE
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE FORGES.
BARGES HI BRADFORD BRADFORD I
CHIANG.
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER.
HELLO.
HELLO HI WESSEL.
WHY SO I JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NIELSEN I PORTANTINO.
TINO AYE RUBIO.
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER I THAT'S TEN THAT'S
DOUBLE THE THE ROLE OPEN --
THE FIRST ITEM ORGAN HERE THIS
MORE CENTER JACKSON HAS --
TWO BILLS SHE'S ASKED --
FOR SB ONE SIXTY NINE TO LEAD
OFF.
GOOD SENATOR GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES --
WE'RE WAITING.
FOR A WITNESS ON THE THER ITEM
WHO IS IN A CURRENTLY A SMALL
CRASH THIS MORNING SO HE'S A
LITTLE DELAYED AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR INDULGENCE AND STARTING.
WITH FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN A
MEASURE ON PIPELINE SAFETY --
THIS BILL WILL STRENGTHEN SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT OF INTRA.
STATE OIL PIPELINES THAT MEANS
WERE ALL WITHIN STATE LINE SO IT
IS A STATE.
OBLIGATION AND IS NOT SUBJECT TO
FEDERAL RULES BECAUSE WE ARE
TALKING ONLY ABOUT THAT OIL
WHICH IS TRANSPORTED WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA.
AND IT WILL STRENGTHEN THOSE
SAFETY ENFORCEMENT.
REQUIREMENTS BY ENSURING THAT
THOSE PIPELINES ARE COVERED BY
OUR STATE CRITICAL SAFETY
PROGRAM REGARDLESS OF OPERATING
PRESSURE.
M. BY BOLSTERING OUR REGULATORS
ABILITY TO REQUEST READ RECORDS
FROM OERATORS.
NOTABLY THE BILL CLOSES N
EXEMPTION. FOR PIPELINES THAT
OPERATE OFTEN AT VERY LOW
PRESSURES OFTEN DOING SO TO
AVOID HAVING TO COMPLY WITH
CALIFORNIA'S REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL SPECIFIES
THE KINDS OF RECORDS THAT MUST
BE KEPT BY PIPELINE OPERATORS
AND AUTHORIZES THE OFFICE OF
STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO REQUEST
THOSE RECORDS FOR INSPECTION
PURPOSES.
SO WHY WHY THIS BILL.
WELL AFTER THE CATASTROPHIC
TWENTY FIFTEEN REVIEW FUEL OIL
SPILL IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY.
THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED TO TWO
IMPORTANT PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THE GREATLY ENHANCE OUR STATE
OIL PIPELINE SAFETY PROGRAM.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIXTY FOUR
PHONE TWO EMPLOYEE BEST
AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGIES.
IT SHOULDN'T BE TOO DIFFICULT
BUT JUST SIMPLY SAID YOU HAVE TO
APPLY THOSE BEST EMPLOY THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES.
AND A BILL I AUTHORED SB.
TWO NINETY FIVE UP THE
INSPECTION INTERVAL TO ANNUALLY
RATHER THAN USING THE FEDERAL
BASIS OF EVERY FIVE YEARS.
THEN IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN AGAIN IN ALAMEDA.
THERE WAS --
WERE TO RUPTURES OF OIL.
PIPELINES THAT WERE BECAUSE
SIMILARLY BY CORROSIVE PIPELINES
HAD THEY BEEN INSPECTED MORE
REGULARLY WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO IDENTIFY.
THAT THESE PROBLEMS EXISTED AND
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN CORRECTED
BEFORE THESE SPILLS OCCURRED.
NOW.
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE SINCE THAT
BILL PASSED WE HAVE SEEN A
NUMBER OF COMPANIES TRY TO AVOID
COMPLIANCE OR AVOID
PARTICIPATION IN THAT ANNUAL --
SAFETY SYSTEM.
BY REDUCING THE PRESSURE TO
BELOW THE AMOUNT THAT IS
REQUIRED IN ORDER.
TO PROVIDE THOSE ANNUAL REPORTS
OTHER AMENDMENTS TO THE STATE'S
PIPELINE REGULATORY PROGRAM THAT
WERE MADE TO CONFORM WITH STATE
WITH FEDERAL LAW.
LEAVE A GAP IN OUR STATE PROGRAM
THAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO CLOSE.
SPECIFICALLY.
THIS BILL TO LEAD TO AN
EXEMPTION IN STATE LAW THAT WAS
TAKEN TO CONFORM WITH FEDERAL
LAW BACK IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT EXCUSE ME
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SO MANY
MANY YEARS AGO WE WERE.
LOOKING TO HAVE THAT CONSISTENCY
WITH FEDERAL LAW.
AND THAT EXCLUDED PIPELINES
OPERATING UNDER 20% OF THEIR
SPECIFIED MAXIMUM YIELD PRESSURE.
FROM STATE OVERSIGHT THEY WOULD
BE FEDERALLY NOT REQUIRED BY THE
STATE THAT IS SORT OF THE THE
DEFAULT THAT THESE COMPANIES ARE
TRYING TO USE NOW TO AVOID
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR HIGHER
STANDARD WHICH EXIST BY THE WAIT
FOR PRACTICAL REASONS AND THAT
IS WE HAVE DISCOVERED IS
MENTIONED --
THE CORROSIVE NATURE THESE
PIPELINES WHICH IF NOT ADDRESSED
BY STUDYING ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
CAN AND HAVE CAUSED.
EXTREME CONDITIONS.
AND ECONOMIC DISASTERS FRANKLY
THAT OCCURRED IN MY DISTRICT AND
I KNOW ONE ALAMEDA THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THESE OIL SPILLS.
ON THE ENVIRONMENT AND ON THE
ECONOMY ARE SIGNIFICANT SO
DELETING THIS EXEMPTION IS
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
REGULAR PIPELINES INVOLVED IN
THE TRANSPORT.
OF HAZARDOUS LIQUIDS INCLUDING
OIL ARE INSPECTED ANNUALLY AND
EMPLOY THE BEST AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGIES.
THESE --
THERE A PIPELINE TO CAN BE RUN
FOR EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME
UNDER LOWER.
OPERATING UNDER LOW PRESSURE
THAT STILL TRANSPORT AND
ECONOMIC PRODUCT BUT AGAIN
AREN'T COVERED UNDER THE ARE
STRONGER LAW SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS TIGHTEN THE LAW.
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC IT TO
PROTECT AGAINST THESE EVENTS
OCCURRING AND USING BEST
AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT THESE COMPANIES
SHOULD BE DOING ANYWAY.
ADDITIONALLY THIS MEASURE
SPECIFIES THAT RECORDS MUST BE
PRODUCED UPON INSPECTION BY THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
WHO HAS RESPONSIBILITY IN THE
AREA OF OIL TRANSPORT.
CURRENTLY THE LAW IS UNCLEAR
ABOUT THE TYPE THE TYPES OF
RECORDS THAT MUST BE COMPILED
COLLECTED AND PRODUCED AND THE
AUTHORITY OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL TO COMPEL RECORDS WAS
ALSO UNCLEAR.
SO THIS BILL WILL BOTH FOR THE
FAR AND THE CALL TO PRODUCE
THOSE -- FOR
THERE WAS THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
LISTED WE JUST RECEIVED A VERY
LATE OPPOSITION --
BY THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION --
THEIR CONCERNS AS I UNDERSTAND
IT HAVE TO DO WITH THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THESE RECORDS
A TO THE EXTENT THAT THEIR
CONCERNS DON'T IN ANY WAY IMPEDE
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY.
TO WORK WITH THEM IT IS NOT OUR
INTENT TO REVEAL ANY KIND OF
TRADE SECRETS OF THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL IS EXACTLY AS I HAVE
ARTICULATED HERE TODAY.
AND WE WILL CERTAINLY BE HAPPY
TO WORK.
WITH THE ANY OPPOSITION THAT.
HAS CONCERNS THAT ARE AGAIN NOT
GOING TO UNDERMINE THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL.
SO WITH ME I HAVE A DAN JACOBSON
FROM ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA TO
SPEAK ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
STRONG STATE STANDARDS.
IN SAFEGUARDING OUR INTRA STATE
HAZARDOUS LIQUID.
PIPELINES AND WITH THAT I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND AGAIN THANK YOU TO
SENATORS. TO SENATOR JACKSON FOR
ONCE AGAIN BRINGING FORWARD SOME
CRITICAL ENVIRONMENTAL
LEGISLATION.
OIL SPILLS ARE DIRTY AND
DANGEROUS AND EVEN A SALL CASE
SOMETIMES IN THE CASE OF
THOUSANDS OR TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF GALLONS IS BAD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS CAUSED
BY THIS BILL CAN REALLY FALL
INTO THREE CATEGORIES FIRST IS
THE WATER CONTAMINATION
OFTENTIMES THESE BILLS WHILE
THEY MAY BE DETECTED WITHIN A
FEW HOURS.
TAKE DAYS IF NOT WEEKS TO GET
CLEANED UP IN WHICH CASE THE OIL
HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEAK INTO
THE GROUND WATER.
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE IN THE
STATE WERE TRYING TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE SAFE AND CLEAN
DRINKING WATER. TWO IS THE LAND
IN SOIL CONTAMINATION SIMILAR TO
THE WATER CONTAMINATION ONCE
THIS OIL LEAKS INTO THE GROUND
IT CAN TAKE YEARS TO CLEAN UP
AND COST TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO DO SO.
AND THIRD OBVIOUSLY THE
ECOSYSTEM IMPACTS THAT ARE
CAUSED BY THESE BILLS NO ONE
NEEDS TO BE REMINDED AGAIN OF
THE SOIL BIRCHER SOILED ANIMALS
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THIS.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ONE SMALL
PLACE IT'S IMPACTED IT'S THE
WHOLE ECOSYSTEM THAT HAS TO FACE
THE IMPACT WHEN WE SEE THESE
BILLS EVEN IF THEY'RE SMALL.
THE SECOND POINT THAT I THINK IS
THAT OIL SPILLS ARE UNAVOIDABLE
WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO HAVE THEM
THERE'S JUST NO GUARANTEE TO
MOVE OIL FROM POINT A TO POINT
B. ENSURE THAT THERE'S NO LEAKS.
SOMETIMES THESE LEAKS ARE LARGE
THANKFULLY THAT'S A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE TIME BUT THE
SMALL LEAKS ADD UP THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF THE SMALL LEAKS
CONTINUE TO HAVE AN IMPACT ON
OUR ENVIRONMENT.
IN -- WE
NEED TO BE DOING EVERYTHING
ENSURE THAT EVERY FORM OF
TRANSPORTATION OF OIL AND OTHER
HAZARDOUS MATERIAL IS DONE AS
SAFELY AS POSSIBLE IN.
ALL JUST END BY SAYING THAT WE
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN DO THIS IN A SAFER
FASHION.
AND WE SHOULD BE DOING OBVIOUSLY
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY DROP OF OIL OR OTHER
HAZARDOUS MATERIAL THAT WE'RE
MOVING IN THE STATE.
CAN BE DONE SO IT DOESN'T IMPACT
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND IT HAS NO
IMPACT ON OUR HEALTH.
I'LL CLOSE BY SAYING OBVIOUSLY
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THERE ARE
TIMES TO ROLL BACK SOME OF THE
BASIC PROTECTIONS THAT WE'RE
SEEING WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE
CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY STAYS THE
COURSE.
BUT CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THIS ISSUE WITH THAT I'D SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND ASHLEY
RIVAL.
ANYBODY ELSE IN FAVOR.
CASING NINE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION.
MORNING TERM YOU MAKE YOU MAY
COME UP HERE.
GET A BIG KIDS SEE TODAY.
MORE.
SO FOUR STAR ACCOUNT I'VE KIND
OF FILL DID USE FOUR STARS ARE
RULES ARE --
TO UP TO TWO SPEAKER SEASIDE FOR
TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WILL BE
VERY BRIEF FUND WE CENTERS WITH
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION AGAIN WE APOLOGIZE
FOR THE VERY LATE LETTER --
I DON'T THINK WE DISAGREE WITH
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT OF THIS BILL
AND ENSURING PROPER PROTECTIONS
HOWEVER.
AS A BY PRODUCT OF ENHANCING
WHAT THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL MAY --
RECEIVE AND HOW THE THE DATA WE
JUST WANT TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TO DEVELOP LANGUAGE OUT
TO PROVIDE PROPER CONTROLS
REGARDING.
THE SHARING OF DATA --
THAT SEEM APPROPRIATE AND HOW
THE US OF I SHARES AND
DISTRIBUTES THAT DATA --
AND AND TO WHOM SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
A MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
PAY HOST REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT PETROVSKY
HATE OIL SPILLS WE HATE --
ANIMALS MARINE MAN ANIMALS
COVERED IN OIL IT'S A HORRIBLE --
IT'S AWFUL ENVIRONMENTAL
DEGRADATION WE WE WE SUPPORT THE
SENATORS --
EFFORTS TO ENHANCE THE STATE'S
ALL SAFETY PIPELINE PROGRAM BUT
LIKE THE PREVIOUS WITNESS --
WE ARE OPPOSE BECAUSE OF
CONFIDENTIALITY CONCERNS --
OTHER BILLS THAT WE'VE HAD OVER
THE YEARS BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
WE'VE HAD THE SAME CONCERNS.
AND YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO DEAL
WITH THAT INFORMATION AND ASSET
THAT SAME BE DONE HERE --
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSE AND LESS AMEND.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE PULL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
MR GORGEOUS.
THEY GIVE A STRUCTURE.
A GOOD MORNING.
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY A COUPLE
OF THINGS SO [inaudible]
CAN YOU.
A REAL ADDRESS THE THE FEDERAL
OBLIGATION TO OVERSEE PIPELINES.
AND IN WHAT IS YOUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION.
IS PULLING BACK THE OVERSIGHT OF
THOSE PIPELINES WAS THAT ONLY
INTERSTATE OR INTRASTATE
INSPECTION AS WELL THE FEDERAL
RESPONSIBILITIES INTERSTATE
CALIFORNIA HAS RESPONSIBILITY IN
TRUST STATE.
WHAT WE DID BACK IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WAS TRYING TO FALL
THE FEDERAL REGULATION OF EVERY
FIVE YEARS --
WE WE'VE FOUND IS RESULTS SADLY
THAT THAT IS NOT ADEQUATE THAT
THE CORROSIVE NATURE OF THESE
PIPELINES IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE.
LOOKING AT ON AN ANNUAL BASIS SO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU RESPECTIVELY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS DOING OR IS
PLANNING TO DO SAID YOU KNOW
WHAT FIVE YEARS I INADEQUATE
AND WE ARE GOING TO REQUIRE.
THAT THE THERE'D BE AN
INSPECTION ANNUALLY AND IN FACT
AND YOU COULD ARGUE TO IN PART
THAT THE NATURE OF THE OIL TODAY
IS INDEED FAR MORE CORROSIVE
THAN IT WAS BACK --
THIRTY FORTY YEARS AGO HE HELPED
ME HONE IN STATE ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT THE NETWORK ITSELF WE TALK
ABOUT THE ACTUAL PIECE OF PIPING.
FIVE THE NET IT'S BASICALLY THE
NETWORK SO WHAT WE DO IS WE
DRILL OIL FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THIS INSTANCE
THAT HAPPENED --
A COUPLE YEARS AGO --
UP IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
DRILL IT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND THEN TO HYPE IT UP TO THE
REFINERIES IN THE BAY AREA.
SO THAT IS INTRA STATE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
NOT WE'RE NOT DEALING WITH
ANYTHING ON A FEDERAL BASIS
WHICH IS DEALING WITH WHAT WE
CAN DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AND REGARDING THE CONCERNS
OF PROPRIETARY INFORMATION THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM TO THE
REPRESENTATIVES HERE FROM WAS BY
A WITH THIS BE SUBJECT TO A
PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT IF
IT GOES.
TO THROUGH THE FIRE MARSHAL.
YEAH I THINK IT'S TWO FOLD I
THINK IT'S A COULD BE SUBJECT TO
A PUBLIC RECORDS REQUEST AND
LOOK AGENCIES DO THEIR BASS WHEN
THEY COMPILE A LARGE AMOUNT OF
DATA THAT THAT DATA CAN GET OUT.
IN THESE ARE YOU KNOW SOFT
TARGETS AS EASY FOR US.
TO SECURE THE BORDERS OF OUR
PROPERTY BUT WHEN YOU GET HAVE
PIPELINES THAT RUN MILES YOU
KNOW THERE ARE A CONCERN OF ALL
TYPES OF ENVIRONMENTAL TERRORISM --
OTHER CONCERNS OF REVOLVING
AROUND THE SAFETY THOSE
PIPELINES AND AGAIN --
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT COMPLAINING
HERE ABOUT THE ENHANCE SAFETY
IT'S WHICH REALLY JUST SOME OF
THE CONFERENCE OUT OF THAT
INFORMATION.
IN YOUR OKAY AS LONG AS MEMBERS
ARE BEING MADE BY THE MAKER OF
THE ITEM.
WELL WE WOULD WOULD HAVE TO SEE
THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE ULTIMATELY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ANYONE ELSE CENTER ARCHULETA
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR UP
CENTER I I THOUGHT YOUR
PRESENTATION WAS EXCELLENT BUT
BE PERFECTLY HONEST WITH YOU.
THE ENVIRONMENT THE OIL
TRANSPORTATION --
OF AT AND I THINK YOU ADDRESSED
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT THE PRIVACY
THAT YOU ALSO SAID THAT YOU
WOULD BE WORKING WITH HIM TO
FIND A COMPROMISE.
SO -- THAT
WOULD BE IN THE PART AND THE
QUALITY OF OF THE MESSAGE AND DE
CAREFUL TO DISSEMINATE IT TO THE
WRONG PARTIES AND SO ON SO I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO LOOK AT
THAT. TO MAKE SURE THE SECURITY --
IN THE INFORMATION IS IS HANDLED
CORRECT.
THE GOAL IS A IS I UNDERSTAND IT
IS THE CONFIDENTIALITY.
THE FIRE MARSHAL OF MY ON MY
EXPERIENCE AND UNDERSTAND IS
THAT INFORMATION IS NOT
DISSEMINATED.
BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN
RESOLVE ANY.
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
WE'RE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU AND I'M AND I'M REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
BRING IN THIS BEFORE US BECAUSE
ALL OF US ARE CONCERNED ABOUT%
OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AND THE TRANSPORTATION OF OF OUR
OILS AND SO ON SO I APPRECIATE I
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
CENTER GALGIANI --
I WANNA THANK YOU AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY BUT I
TO SHARE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROPER CONTROLS FOR THE SHARING
OF DATA AND TRUST THAT.
YOU WORK WITH THE OPPONENTS AND
COME UP WITH SOME LANGUAGE THAT
THAT IDENTIFIES THE CASES IN
WHICH THEY CAN SHARE THE DATA
[inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY.
I'M GOING TO ECHO THE THE
SENATOR'S COMMENTS --
IN MY OWN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT I
HAD ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER I
FELT LIKE IT WAS IT WAS UNDER
REGULATED --
IN HINDSIGHT IT WAS --
JUST WRITTEN JUST READ THE THE
OPPOSITION SO THEY DO HAVE
CONSENT SOME CONCERNS YOU MADE A
PLACE HERE TODAY TO TO WORK WITH
THE OTHER SIDE AND SO I'M A VOTE
FOR YOUR BILL TODAY RESERVE THE
RIGHT IF WE DON'T COME TO
AGREEMENT TO CHANGE MY MIND
LATER.
BUT WITH THAT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
TO THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVE SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND CALL THE FILE
ITEM SIX SB ONE SIXTY NINE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD.
WILK HI WILK AYE ALLEN
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE FORGES FORGES AYE
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER.
HILL.
HILL I WEST SO I JONES
[inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NOW PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
[inaudible]
WIENER.
WIENER I WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
[inaudible]
THIS. TEN TO ONE SO ATTENDED ONE
IT'S OUT WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON IN THIS
BILL MOVES ON TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
A KEY CENTER WILL.
NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE
ITEM.
THREE SB FORTY SIX ONCE AGAIN
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS [inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
OKAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT.
TO FOR THE SENATE BILL FORTY SIX
IT IS A MEASURE THAT EXPANDS.
MY ALERT IN WARNING BILL FROM
LAST YEAR WHICH WAS AS BE A
TWENTY ONE THIS BILL EXPANDS
THAT MEASURE BY ALLOWING CITIES
AND UNIVERSITIES TO
AUTOMATICALLY.
ENROLL STUDENTS RESIDENTS AND
EMPLOYEES IN LOCALLY OPERATED
EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEMS WHILE
PRESERVING THEIR ABILITY TO OPT
OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
SB FORTY SIX CLARIFIES THAT
ALERTING AUTHORITIES MAY USE
WIRELESS TELEPHONE SUBSCRIBER
DATA. FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE.
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF PROVIDING
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS.
AND ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
IDENTIFY RESIDENTS WITH ACCESS
AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS.
IN ORDER TO SEND THEM
SPECIALIZED EMERGENCY ALERTS.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES
TELECOMMUNICATIONS OPERATORS TO
ANNUALLY PRODUCE DATA CONCERNING
THE PERFORMANCE OF WIRELESS
INFRASTRUCTURE USED TO SEND
EMERGENCY ALERTS THE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS.
COLLEAGUES AS YOU WELL KNOW.
AND HAVE IN MANY INSTANCES
EXPERIENCED.
THE LARGEST AND MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRE SEASONS IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY.
A COMBINATION OF YEARS OF
DROUGHT FUELS ACCUMULATION AND
CLIMATE CHANGE INTO SEVERE
WEATHER.
WHICH HAS RESULTED IN WILDFIRES
OF UNPRECEDENTED SIZE AND
INTENSITY WHICH HAVE KILLED OVER
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
CALIFORNIANS DESTROYED THOUSANDS
OF HOMES.
AND BURNED OVER WELL OVER A
MILLION ACRES OF LAND.
THESE FREQUENT LARGE SCALE WATER
FIRES HAVE FOCUSED ATTENTION ON
HOW CALIFORNIA WARNS THE PUBLIC
DURING EMERGENCIES.
IN THE OLD DAYS THE CHURCH BELLS
RANG.
WHEN I WAS A KID GOING GROWING
UP WE HAD THE CONRAD?
EARLY WARNING SYSTEM WE THOUGHT
WE WERE GOING TO RUSSIA BIG
SYSTEM WOULD GO OFF ON YOUR
RADIO OR IN THE COMMUNITY WE
DON'T HAVE THOSE ANYMORE.
SO THE QUESTION IS WHAT DO WE DO
WHEN WE ARE SORT OF FACING AN
EMERGENCY WHEN A WILDFIRE IS
MOVING AT RAPID SPEED HOW DO WE
LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT THEY ARE IN
DANGER.
AND WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO GET
OUT OF HARM'S WAY.
THESE FREQUENT FIRES HAVE SHOWN
US THE HOLES IN OUR SYSTEM.
AND ART AND THE FACT THAT ARE
WARNING SYSTEMS COME IN A
VARIETY OF FORMS AND EACH HAS
SPECIFIC CAPABILITIES AS WELL AS
DRAWBACKS SYSTEMS RANGE FROM
RELATIVELY LOW TECH OPTIONS.
LIKE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
LITERALLY GOING DOOR TO DOOR. TO
TELL PEOPLE THEY MUST VACATE. TO
OUTDOOR WARNING SIRENS TO AUTO
DARLING TELEPHONES THAT CAN
RELAY DETAILED EMERGENCY
INFORMATION TO HOUSES AT A BLOCK
BY BLOCK LEVEL. ONE OF THE MORE
MODERN SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE WEST IS THE A LOT --
WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM
THE OUIJA SYSTEM IT'S CALLED.
ADMINISTERED BY FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION'S.
COMMISSION WE ARE ALLOWS MOBILE
PHONE SUBSCRIBERS TO RECEIVE
GEOGRAPHICALLY TARGETED TAX LIKE
MESSAGES ALERTING THEM OF
IMMINENT THREATS TO SAFETY IN
THEIR AREA.
BUT IT TOO HAS ITS LIMITATIONS
BECAUSE IT LACKS.
ACTUAL PRECISION IT'S VERY SHORT
IN TERMS OF THE MESSAGING IT CAN
DO AND THERE'S NO WAY FOR TWO
WAY COMMUNICATION.
AS AN EXAMPLE DURING OUR FAR TWO
THIRTY IN THE MORNING MY CELL
PHONE WENT OFF WITH THE WE ALERT.
RIGHT NO IDEA WHERE EXACTLY THE
PROBLEM WAS WAS IT TEN MILES
AWAY WAS IT FIVE MILES AWAY WAS
IT NEXT DOOR AND I COULD NOT
INTERACT WITH IT TO FIND OUT
JUST EXACTLY WHERE THIS
EMERGENCY WAS OCCURRING.
NOW MANY JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND BY THE WAY DID
SCARE THE HECK OUT OF ME AS WELL.
AND IT WAS HARD GOING BACK TO
SLEEP AFTER THAT AND MANY OF MY
NEIGHBORS AND THE PEOPLE WITHIN
THIS WE A SYSTEM GOT THE SAME
TEXT AND THE LORD AND ALSO DID
NOT KNOW WHAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO DO.
SO MANY JURISDICTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA SUPPLEMENTS SYSTEMS
LIKE WE ARE.
WITH THEIR OWN LOCALLY OPERATED
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS
IN ORDER TO A MORE EFFECTIVELY
COMMUNICATE WITH RESIDENTS
DURING AN EMERGENCY.
THE SYSTEM SOMEONE CALLED NICK
SOUL CODE RED AND OTHERS.
CAN SEND PRE RECORDED MESSAGES
TO LAND LINE TELEPHONES LOCATED
WITHIN A DEFINED TARGET AREA.
AS WELL AS SEND TEXT INVOICE A
LARGE TO MOBILE TELEPHONES WHICH
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE ARE USING
TO THE EXCLUSION OF LAND LINE SO
THEY BECOME A CRITICAL PLAYER.
IN THIS EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM.
GIVEN THE UNIQUE ABILITY TO
TARGET ALERTS USING PHYSICAL
ADDRESSES LOCALLY OPERATED NO
NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS ARE AMONG
THE MOST PRECISE EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS IN USE
TODAY.
BUT BECAUSE REGISTRATION OF
MOBILE PHONES WAS NOT UNTIL
RECENTLY AN AUTOMATIC PROCESS
MANY JURISDICTIONS HAVE
STRUGGLED TO GET RESIDENTS TO
SIGN UP TO RECEIVE THESE ALERTS.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN THE THOMAS FIRE
THEN THE LARGEST FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY BROKE OUT IN
MY DISTRICT.
LESS THAN 30% OF RESIDENTS IN
THE AFFECTED AREA HAD ACTUALLY
SIGNED UP TO RECEIVE COUNTY
GENERATED CELL PHONE AND EMAIL
ALERTS LESS THAN 30%.
SO LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB EIGHT TWENTY ONE WHICH
AUTHORIZED COUNTY EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT OFFICIALS TO
AUTOMATICALLY ENROLL RESIDENTS
IN COUNTY OPERATED SYSTEMS.
IT ENSURES THAT RESIDENTS WHO DO
NOT SEE THESE ALERTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OPT OUT.
YOU'RE IN UNLESS YOU DON'T WANT
TO BE AND THEN YOU CAN OPT OUT.
AND IT ALSO SPECIFICALLY
RESTRICTS COUNTIES FROM USING
PERSONAL INFORMATION THAT THEY
OBTAIN TO ENROLL RESIDENTS IN
THIS NOTIFICATION SYSTEM FOR ANY.
OTHER PURPOSE PERIOD.
IT IS NOT AVAILABLE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR ANY OTHER
PURPOSE THAN THESE ALERTS
BECAUSE THAT IS THE SOLE AND
SINGULAR FUNCTION.
OF THESE ALERT PROGRAMS THIS
BILL WAS A NECESSARY STEP TOWARD
INCREASING THE PERCENTAGE OF
RESIDENTS WHO RECEIVE EMERGENCY
ALERTS FROM COUNTY OFFICIALS BUT
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO IMPROVE
THE DISSEMINATION AND UTILITY.
OF MESSAGES SENT.
AND WE SAW SUBSEQUENT FIRES WE
SAW THE WALLS THE FIRE WHERE
STUDENTS WERE ASKED --
TO STAY ON SITE WE CALL IT.
SHELTERING ON SITE HOW DID THEY
KNOW TO DO THAT WELL IT TURNS
OUT THAT A LOT OF THE UNIVERSITY
POLICE DEPARTMENTS ACTUALLY DID
NOT HAVE ACCESS. TO THEIR
INFORMATION THE SAME THING IT TO
US CSU CHANNEL ISLANDS TO MY
DISTRICT WHICH HAS SUFFERED A
FEW A COUPLE FIRES OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
HOW DO YOU LET THE STUDENTS KNOW
AND SO THE BILL THIS YEAR ADD
CITIES?
AND UNIVERSITIES TO THE PROGRAM
SO THAT THEY CAN WARN STUDENTS
AND WARN PEOPLE WITHIN THEIR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ABOUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING AND WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO.
TO BE SAFE UNDER THESE HORRIFIC
SORT BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
MORE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
RECEIVED CRITICAL EMERGENCY
ALERTS BY EXPANDING THE OP OUT
SYSTEM.
IT CLARIFIES THAT ALERTING
AUTHORITIES MAY USE WIRELESS
TELEPHONE SUBSCRIBER DATA TO
ENROLL RESIDENTS IN THE SYSTEMS
AGAIN IT MAINTAINS THE SAME
PROTECTIONS.
THAT EXIST THAT THESE CAN ONLY
BE USED FOR A VERY SPECIFIC AND
LIMITED PURPOSE.
AND IT ALSO AUTHORIZES COUNTY
SOCIAL SERVICE DEPARTMENTS WE
LEARN THIS IS WELL.
WE LEARNED THIS IN THE PARADISE
FAR WE LEARNED THIS IN THE FIRES
UP IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT
THERE ARE PEOPLE WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS WHO NEED TO BE NOTIFIED AT
THE EARLIEST POSSIBLE STAGE.
SO THAT EFFORTS CAN BE MADE TO
EVACUATE THEM SO THAT THEY DON'T
END UP AS VICTIMS AS ONE OF THE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO PLUS
PEOPLE.
WHO WERE KILLED DURING THE MOST
RECENT FIRES SO?
WHEN DISASTER STRIKES COLLEAGUES
EMERGENCY OFFICIALS MUST BE ABLE
TO NOTIFY RESIDENTS QUICKLY AND
EFFECTIVELY?
THE MEASURE ALSO SAYS THAT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS WHO
ARE NOW A KEY COMPONENT OF THIS
WHOLE SYSTEM.
HAVE TO SUPPLY THE P. YOU SEE
WITH SPECIFIC DATA REGARDING
EMERGENCY MESSAGING PERFORMANCE.
ERROR RATES AND THROUGH PORTS ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS IT'S AGGREGATED
NO ONE'S GOING TO KNOW WHO
SPECIFICALLY WHAT COMPANIES
DOING WHAT BUT BECAUSE THESE
COMPANIES ARE PART.
OF THIS WARNING SYSTEM THEY NEED
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT NGUYEN MANY OF
THESE A LARGE CAME OUT IN MY
DISTRICT.
MANY OF MY FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES RECEIVE THE NOTICES
AND MANY DID NOT.
THE SYSTEM IS NOT PERFECT AND WE
MUST IMPROVE IT AND WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
AS I HAVE WITH ME JEFF NORRIS
THE EMERGENCY SERVICE
COORDINATOR FOR SAN MATTEO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND
CHIEF MICHAEL MORRIS FROM CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY CHANNEL ISLANDS
WHO ARE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
NOT JUST TO REMIND THE SPEAKERS
SAID TWO MINUTES EACH.
THANK YOU OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
MICHAEL MORRIS AND I SERVE AS
THE CHIEF OF POLICE FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHANNEL ISLANDS.
DURING THE FALL SEMESTER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CSU CHANNEL
ISLANDS COMMUNITY EXPERIENCE
THREE SIGNIFICANT EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS WITHIN A PERIOD OF
ONLY EIGHT DAYS.
ON OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST A
STUDENT WAS PHYSICALLY ASSAULTED
IN A RESTROOM AND ONE OF OUR
ACADEMIC BUILDINGS AND
THREATENED WITH A HANDGUN.
ONLY ONE WEEK LATER THE TRAGIC
SHOOTING AT BORDERLINE BAR AND
GRILL IN THOUSAND OAKS OCCURRED.
AND ALTHOUGH THAT DID NOT OCCUR
ON CAMPUS WE KNOW THAT AT LEAST
FORTY CHANNEL ISLAND STUDENTS
WERE PRESENT.
AT THE TIME.
THE VERY NEXT DAY NOVEMBER
EIGHTH THE HILL FIRE IN THE WILL
THE FIREBALL STARTED IN THE AREA
WITHIN TWENTY ONE MINUTES OF
EACH OTHER.
BOTH FIRES ULTIMATELY IMPACTED
OUR COMMUNITY BUT THE HILL FIRE
FORCED THE IMMEDIATE MANDATORY
EVACUATION AND THREE DAY CLOSURE
OF THE CHANNEL ISLANDS CAMPUS.
WE'RE THANKFUL THAT NONE OF
THESE INCIDENTS ACTUALLY
RESULTED IN THE LOSS OF LIFE FOR
ANY MEMBER OF THE CHANNEL
ISLANDS COMMUNITY.
PSYCHOLOGICAL TOLL HOWEVER WAS
DEVASTATING FOR A COMMUNITY.
INTO THESE INCIDENTS BECAME
NECESSARY FOR US TO ACTIVATE OUR
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION SYSTEM TO
ALERT STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES OF
THE PRESENCE OF DANGER.
WE USE A SYSTEM FOR MASS
NOTIFICATION WHICH DISTRIBUTES
MESSAGES BY MEANS OF EMAIL
TELEPHONE CALL AND TEXT MESSAGE.
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
COMMAND AND EMPLOYEES ARE IN
AUTOMATICALLY ENROLLED IN THIS
SYSTEM BUT ONLY WITH THEIR
CAMPUS EMAIL ADDRESS.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO OPT IN
AND TO VOLUNTARY VOLUNTARILY ADD
SUPPLEMENTAL CONTACT INFORMATION
TO THE SYSTEM INCLUDING THEIR
CELLPHONES.
WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE OUR
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES TO DO SO
TO PROVIDE THE SUPPLEMENTAL
CONTACT INFORMATION WE TALK
ABOUT IT REGULARLY.
AT ORIENTATIONS EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS --
PROGRAMMING SOCIAL MEDIA AND
GLOBAL EMAIL MESSAGES BUT FOR
WHATEVER REASON MANY PEOPLE JUST
DON'T DO IT.
FOLLOWING THE THREE INCIDENTS
LAST FALL.
WE HAD A DEBRIEFING PROCESS
INVOLVING PRESIDENT ERICA BACK
IN HER LEADERSHIP TEAM.
WE DISCUSS THE STRENGTHS AND
WEAKNESSES OF THE UNIVERSE THESE
EMERGENCIES AND THE IMPACT THAT
THEY HAD ON OUR COMMUNITY.
WE DISCUSSED OUR EXPERIENCES
WITH EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION AND
THE FACT THAT SO MANY STUDENTS
HAVE REPORTED TO US THAT THEY
HAD NEVER RECEIVED OUR MESSAGES.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
OUR OWN INFORMATION SYSTEMS USED
TO MANAGE ENROLLMENT
REGISTRATION IN PERSONNEL
RECORDS.
ACTUALLY CONTAIN CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING THEIR CELL
PHONE NUMBERS BUT THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT INCLUDED IN
OUR EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION
SYSTEM.
IT MAKES SENSE TO TAKING A FULL
INFORMATION THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
BEEN LOADED INTO THE EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM.
AND GIVE PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO OPT OUT OF THAT SYSTEM RATHER
THAN TO TRY TO CONVINCE THEM TO
OPT IN.
DON'T DO IT THAT WAY BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE TO BE UNLAWFUL. FOR US
TO UTILIZE STUDENTS PHONE
NUMBERS FOR THAT PURPOSE WITHOUT
THEIR CONSENT.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL BE
VERY WILL BE VERY BENEFICIAL FOR
OUR CAMPUS.
DURING AN EMERGENCY WE KNOW THAT
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES ARE NOT
NECESSARILY GOING TO CHECK THEIR
EMAIL FOR INFORMATION AND
INSTRUCTIONS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN EMAILS PROBABLY NOT THE
COMMUNICATING WITH THIS
GENERATION OF COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THEY ARE HOWEVER VERY CONNECTED
TO THEIR MOBILE DEVICES WE NEED
TO RESET THEY NEED TO RECEIVE A
PHONE CALL OR TEXT MESSAGE ON
THEIR CELL PHONE.
HAVING THE ABILITY TO ALERT OUR
STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES TO THE
PRESENCE OF AN EMERGENCY AND TO
BE CONFIDENT THAT EVERY PERSON
RECEIVED THAT NOTIFICATION
IMMEDIATELY IS CRITICAL.
THIS BILL WILL HELP TO MAKE THAT
POSSIBLE.
WE APPRECIATE SENATOR JACKSON
FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL WHICH
WE BELIEVE WILL PROVIDE THE
TOOLS TO HELP KEEP OUR STUDENTS
AND EMPLOYEES SAFE.
YOU ALSO HELP OTHER COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WHO STRUGGLE WITH
THE SAME CHALLENGES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE YOU
KEEPING THAT UNDER TWO MINUTES
HI I'M NEXT SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING JEFF NORRIS
EMERGENCY SERVICES COORDINATOR
FOR THE COUNTY OF SAN MATTEO.
SENATOR COUNTY HAS BEEN
OPERATING AN OPT IN ALERT AND
WARNING SYSTEM THE SMC ALERT FOR
A LITTLE OVER TEN YEARS NOW AND
WE'RE APPROACHING ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SUBSCRIBERS.
OUR RESIDENT POPULATION SAN
MATEO COUNTY IS SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE SO WE
HAVE BARELY AN EIGHTH OF OUR
POPULATION UNDER COVERAGE.
ON TOP OF THAT WE OPERATE A
REVERSE NINE ONE ONE EIGHT
TELEPHONE NOTIFICATION SYSTEM
THAT CAN DO VOICE CALLS --
THIS SYSTEM WHEN WE MIGRATED
SOFTWARE APPROXIMATELY THREE
YEARS AGO I MOVED SLIGHTLY OVER
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND TELEPHONE
NUMBERS EACH ONE OF THESE
TELEPHONE NUMBERS HAD A GEO CODE
WHICH RESULTED IN.
IT BEING A MARK ON A HOUSE OR
RESIDENTS.
WHEN I UPDATED THE DATA JUST A
FEW WEEKS AGO --
WHICH IS DONE ON A MONTHLY BASIS
I HAD SLIGHTLY UNDER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND I WATCHED A
THIRD OF THE AVAILABLE
RESIDENCES IN MY COMMUNITY.
THAT MAY NEED NOTIFICATION A
MAJOR EMERGENCY VANISH IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS.
WITH THE HELP OF THIS BILL
SENATOR JACKSON'S DIRECTION WE
WILL BE ABLE TO ENHANCE AND BE
ABLE.
TO LOCATE THOSE PHONE NUMBERS.
IN A CHANGING DYNAMIC.
WE SEE A CHANGING COMMUNICATIONS
DYNAMIC CONVENTIONAL WIRE LINE
TELEPHONES ARE RAPIDLY GOING
AWAY REPLACED WITH TECHNOLOGIES
LIKE VOICE OVER IP THROUGH CABLE
TV.
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE STRICTLY ON
CELLULAR THESE --
COMMUNICATIONS METHODS THAT WE
NOW CANNOT DRAW A CIRCLE ON A
MAP AND SEND A MESSAGE.
TO WE A IS A MARVELOUS
TECHNOLOGY.
BUT IT IS A ONE AND DONE
STRATEGY WHEN IT SENDS A MESSAGE
IF YOUR PHONE IS IN A LOW SIGNAL
OR HIGH NOISE AREA.
YOU WON'T GET THAT MESSAGE THIS
IS PART OF THE REASON WHY MANY
PEOPLE ARE NOT RECEIVING WE A
MESSAGES WHEN OTHERS WHO ARE
WITHIN A FEW HUNDRED YARDS ARE
RECEIVING IT.
WE STRONGLY HAS EMERGENCY
MANAGERS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE STRONGLY HOPE THAT YOU WILL
ADVANCE THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
THIS WILL HELP US.
WE LIKE TO USE THE ACRONYM
PLEASE PLAN LEAVE EARLY AND SAVE
EVERYONE THAT'S OUR MANTRA FOR
EVERY EVACUATION --
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS
AND SUPPORT WE COULD WE CAN DO
ME TO USE OVER HERE OFF TO THE
SIDE.
SEEING NONE IT ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
CAN AS I SHARED EARLIER --
TO SPEAKERS TWO MINUTES --
I'M A GIVE YOU A LITTLE LONGER
LEASH BECAUSE THE PROPONENTS
WENT OVER SO.
IN YOU TAKE THAT IN
CONSIDERATION WHEN YOU GIVE YOUR
TESTIMONY.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CENTER
JACKSON --
STEVE CARLSON --
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
CTI A WHERE THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY TRADE ASSOCIATION.
THE WIRELESS INDUSTRY PLAYS AN
INDISPENSABLE ROLE IN PUBLIC
SAFETY FROM DELIVERING OVER 75%
OF NINE ONE ONE CALLS TO DOES
DISASTER ALERT AND RESPONSE
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF HOW WELL IT
IS DONE.
IN MYRIAD DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES.
AS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED WIRELESS
EMERGENCY ALERTS --
AND IT'S ALSO DESCRIBED TO VERY
WELL IN THE ANALYSIS --
IS A FEDERAL PROGRAM IN WHICH
ALL WIRELESS PHONES UP WHEN YOU
BUY YOUR PHONE YOUR OPTED IN TO
WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERTS AND
YOU HAVE TO OPT OUT OF IT --
WHICH IS ONE OF ITS STRENGTHS.
IT'S BY FAR THE MOST ROBUST
WARNING SYSTEM --
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT HASN'T BEEN
USED IN SOME RECENT INCIDENTS
AND TOO FEW CITIES AND COUNTIES
CALLED LOCAL ORIGINATORS.
ARE PREPARED TO USE THE SYSTEM.
NOTHING'S PERFECT --
WE'RE WORKING ON EXPANDING THE
NUMBER OF CHARACTERS TO EXPAND
THE YOU KNOW THE THE INFORMATION
THAT COMES OUT --
BUT IT IS BY FAR THE BEST.
LOCAL EMERGENCY WARNING SYSTEM
CERTAINLY CAN PLAY A ROLE IN
DISASTER AND WE APPLAUD --
THE WITNESSES AT THE TABLE WHO
ARE ARE SO FOCUSED AND AND
COMMITTED TO THIS.
AND IT TO THE FOCUS OF SB FORTY
SIX UNFORTUNATELY RESPECTFULLY
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THE BILL IS
THE RIGHT WAY TO GO ABOUT
ENHANCING THE SYSTEMS.
FIRST PART OF THE BILL SIX TO
CLARIFY THAT WIRELESS SUBSCRIBER
INFORMATION CAN BE --
OPEN TO TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AND ROLLING
RESIDENTS IN A LOCAL EMERGENCY
WARNING SYSTEM.
EVEN THOUGH IT IS VOLUNTARY ON
THE PART LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE
BELIEVE IT RUNS AFOUL OF A. B.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA --
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT AS ONE FOR
MORE FEDERAL LAWS.
FURTHER AND EQUALLY IF NOT MORE
TROUBLING THE BILL REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION TO COLLECT FROM
CARRIERS AND REPORT INFORMATION
REGARDING THE PERFORMANCE OF AN
PLEASE LISTEN TO THIS.
LOCAL EMERGENCY WARNING SYSTEM
NOT THE FEDERAL SYSTEM THOUGHT
THE STUFF WE DO.
SO WE'RE SUPPOSED TO REPORT ON
WHAT THESE GENTLEMEN DO BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION WE DON'T CONTROL IT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IT
RUNS OVER OUR REGULAR --
CARRIER NETWORKS SO WE'RE NOT
SURE YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THAT HAPPENS --
SO IT ASKING US TO REPORT ON
THAT.
HAS OTHER ISSUES BUT CERTAINLY
IT'S INFORMATION OVER WHICH WE
HAVE -- NO
CONTROL --
IT ALSO FLIPS THE PRESUMPTION OF
CONFIDENTIALITY FOR NETWORK
INFORMATION AND NOW TEACHES.
ALTERNATED AGREES.
THE DISCLOSURE OF THIS
INFORMATION CONTRAVENES INDUSTRY
BEST PRACTICES.
AND FCC STATEMENTS REGARDING THE
NEED FOR CONFIDENTIALITY OF THIS
DATA.
WHICH COULD JEOPARDIZE
COMPETITIVELY SENSITIVE
INFORMATION CRITICAL
COMMUNICATIONS INFRASTRUCTURE.
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION AND
TRADE SECRETS.
WE BELIEVE THE BEST WAY TO
HANDLE THESE ISSUES IS THE WAY
WE'VE DONE IT WITH --
YES AN EMERGENCY RESPONDERS AND
MANY MANY OTHER SITUATIONS.
GET THE RIGHT PEOPLE TO SIT
AROUND A TABLE AND WORK THROUGH
THE ISSUES.
EVEN TODAY WIRELESS CARRIERS ARE
WORKING TO FINALIZE A MAN
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING WITH
CALLAWAY US.
AND WORKING COOPERATIVELY WITH
CAL FIRE TO ENSURE THAT
INFORMATION FLOWS ON THESE
ISSUES ARE PROPERLY TAILORED TO
THESE AGENCIES NEEDS.
UNFORTUNATELY UNLESS THOSE
ISSUES WERE ADDRESSED WITH US
RESPECTFULLY CONTINUE TO OPPOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER DEVINE MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL UNLESS
AMENDED I DO WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR AND THEIR SUPPORTERS TO
BRING FORWARD A ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT EMERGENCY
ALERTS.
AND ABOUT THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS AS ALL OF
YOU KNOW EIGHTEEN ANTI AND THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY IS ON THE
FRONTLINE OF EVERY SINGLE
EMERGENCY.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS PARTICULAR
BILL HAS TWO MAJOR PROVISIONS
ONE IN SECTION FOUR AND ONE IN
SECTION.
FIVE THAT WE OBJECT.
TO STEVE SPOKE TO THE ISSUE OF A
OF THE FACT THAT THE BILL
PRESUMES TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS CONTROL THE ALERT
SYSTEMS WE DO NOT.
WANT ALERT ORIGINATORS SUCH AS A
CITY OR A COUNTY SENDS OUT A
WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERT OR
ALERTING PHONE CALLS AS WAS
MENTIONED IN TERMS OF LAND LINES
OR OTHER MESSAGES BY THIRD PARTY
APPS.
OR THIRD PARTY PROVIDERS WE DO
NOT HAVE CONTROL OVER THEIR
SYSTEMS.
WE DO NOT SEE OR HEAR WHAT THESE
MESSAGES SAY WE DO NOT DECIDE
WHERE THE MESSAGES GO THEY
SELECT THAT AUTOMATICALLY IN THE
SYSTEM.
AND WE DO NOT RECEIVE A RECEIPT
OF WHEN THESE MESSAGES ARE
DELIVERED.
BY DESIGN BECAUSE IN AN
EMERGENCY THE SYSTEM WAS
DESIGNED TO AVOID CONGESTION SO
THE WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERT
SYSTEM IS DEFINITELY A ONE WAY
SYSTEM.
THIS IS BECAUSE ALERT
ORIGINATORS USE THIRD PARTY
SOFTWARE. TO CREATE THESE ALERTS
AND DETERMINE WHERE THEY GO.
SECOND SB FORTY SIX SEEKS TO
IMPOSE P. UC REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT WOULD PUBLICLY
DISCLOSE.
HIGHLY CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION
ABOUT NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OPERATIONS [inaudible]
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
ALREADY REPORT NETWORK
PERFORMANCE INFORMATION TO BOTH
THE P. YOU SEE AND THE FCC.
THEY ARE MARKED CONFIDENTIAL AND
PROTECTED WHY.
BECAUSE IT ADDRESSES CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HOMELAND
SECURITY AND PUBLIC SAFETY YOU
DO NOT WANT NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE BEING BROADCAST
TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
SIMPLY PUT SB FORTY SIX IS BUILT
BUT THESE TWO SECTIONS ARE ON
FALSE PREMISES A THAT WE HAVE
THE INFORMATION THAT WE COULD
REPORT.
AND BE IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO BE
PUBLISHING THIS INFORMATION OR
FLIPPING THE PRESUMPTION.
AT THE P. YOU SEE THAT IT SHOULD
BE PUBLIC RATHER THAN PRIVATE.
TO THOSE OF THE MAJOR CONCERNS
WE HAVE NOW LET ME CLOSE BY
SAYING THIS IF YOU LOOK AT THE
WHEEL SYSTEM.
THE WE IS SYSTEM IS THE ONLY
SYSTEM THAT IS AN OPT OUT SYSTEM
IN OTHER WORDS.
EVERYBODY'S IN UNLESS YOU
ACTIVELY TURN WE ARE OFF ON YOUR
WIRELESS DEVICE.
THERE IS NO DATA AND NO EVIDENCE
TO SUGGEST THAT THE WE HAVE
SYSTEM HAS FAILED DURING ANY OF
THESE EMERGENCIES WHEN IT HAS
BEEN USED.
LAST YEAR ALL OF YOU SUPPORTED
AND WE SUPPORTED A BILL BY
SENATOR.
MCGUIRE.
THAT AND EVERY COMMUNITY CITY
COUNTY WHOEVER THE ALERT DOES
IGNEOUS SHOULD BE SIGNED UP FOR
WE ARE.
AND SHOULD HAVE TRAINING ON HOW
TO IMPLEMENT WE ARE.
IN A DISASTER BECAUSE IT IS THE
BEST MOST EFFECTIVE SYSTEM IN
FACT THE WE A SYSTEM ACTUALLY
CAPTURES YOUR WIRELESS DEVICE IF
YOU'RE VISITING AN AREA SO WE
DON'T NEED AN ADDRESS.
IT INCLUDES EVERY WIRELESS
DEVICE WITH YOUR VISITING OR
LIVING IN A PARTICULAR AREA.
SO IT'S A VERY EFFECTIVE OFTEN
AS ONE OF THE WITNESSES JUST
TESTIFIED THEY SPENT TEN YEARS
TRYING TO COMPILE PHONE NUMBERS
AND BARELY HAVE SCRATCHED
EIGHTEEN OR 20% OF THE ENTIRE
POPULATION.
WE ARE IN THAT SAME GEOGRAPHY IS
AUTOMATICALLY A 100% AGAIN
UNLESS YOU'VE TURNED IT OFF.
ARE THE OTHER ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
RAISED IS THE ISSUE OF NINETY
CHARACTERS OF WE THAT IS WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ADOPTED
YEARS AGO BECAUSE IT WAS A
LIMITATION ON THE TECHNOLOGY WE
ARE NOW EXPLORING AND MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE FCC TO EXPAND
THOSE MESSAGES TO THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY CHARACTERS.
SO THE SYSTEM IS BEING IMPROVED
WE'RE INVESTING IN IN MAKING
SURE ADDITIONAL.
OF CHARACTERS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
THESE ALERTS.
LET ME JUST CLOSE BY SAYING THIS
WE'RE ON THE FRONTLINE OF EVERY
DISASTER AND MANY OF YOU.
WHO HAD DISASTERS IN YOUR
DISTRICT HAS SEEN EIGHTEEN TEA
AND OTHER CARRIERS?
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES RESPONDING TO THESE
DISASTERS BOTH IN THE EARLY
ALERT AS WILLING DURING THE
DISASTER AS WELL AS AFTER.
SO WE EMBRACE WHAT SENATOR
HANNAH BETH JACKSON IS
ATTEMPTING TO DO HERE WE BELIEVE
THERE SOME LIMITATIONS IN
SECTION FOUR AND FIVE THAT NEED
TO BE CORRECTED.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND WITH THE
AUTHOR TO IMPROVE THE BILL AND
MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT WE CAN MEET
TO IT OFF HERE TO THE LEFT.
MAIN OPPOSITION SORRY THANK YOU.
I HAVEN'T DONE IT IN HERE OKAY
SAYING --
NINE PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS WILL OPEN WITH SENATOR
NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IN
CENTER JACKSON I'M VERY
DELIGHTED TO BE A CO AUTHOR WITH
YOU ON THIS LEGISLATION.
THE AREAS THAT I PRIVILEGE
REPRESENT HAVE REGULARLY BEEN
VISITED WITH THE GREAT DISASTERS
AND LIST LAST YEAR ONE OF THE
GREATEST.
IN HISTORY.
I DO I DO BUT THERE APPEARED TO
BE SOME UNANTICIPATED.
CONSEQUENCES ARE FACTORS HERE.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF THAT BEEN VERY COOPERATIVE
IN WORKING THE ENTERTAINING SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
RAISED.
ABOUT THE IT TYPICALLY THE HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY SHIFTING --
TO YES AS OPPOSED TO PAY YOU SEE
IS DESIGNED BUILT AND WELL
PRACTICED IN DEALING WITH SUCH
MATTERS OF P. USUALLY IS NOT
IT'S A DIFFERENT KIND OF
AUTHORITY.
AND I THINK THAT BE GREAT
CONFUSION.
SEATING RESPONSIBILITY THEM BUT
THANK YOU FOR BEING WILLING TO
WORK WITH THAT AND THEN OF-COURSE PROPRIETY OR AND
INFORMATION IS REALLY CRITICAL.
AND YOU'VE INDICATED THAT YOU
WORK WITH US IN THE FUTURE AS WE
PROCEED AND I THANK YOU.
FOR THE WILLINGNESS TO DO THAT I
BELIEVE THAT IT CERTAINLY WILL
IMPROVE.
CERTAINLY THERE'S NO QUESTION
AND ONE OF THE PHENOMENA LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THAT'S THE EXTENT
TODAY.
IS HOW RAPIDLY SOME DISASTERS
LIKE FIRES.
CAN ENVELOP US.
QUITE LITERALLY.
IT IS STUNNING.
ENHANCE OUR ABILITY TO REACH AS
MANY PEOPLE AS DIRECTLY AS
POSSIBLE.
THIS --
NECESSARY AND THAT'S THE
DIRECTION THAT YOU'RE TAKING.
AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT.
I WOULD LOVE SO LIKE TO PUBLICLY
THANK SINCE MISTER DEVINE IS
HERE OF AT AND T..
AND OTHER MATTERS IN THE AREA
THAT I REPRESENT AT AND T. HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLY IMMEDIATE.
AND THOROUGHLY HELPFUL IN
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE'VE HAD.
ABOUT NOTIFICATION.
BACK TO THE BILL I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION AND WILLINGNESS
TO ENTERTAIN AMENDMENTS AND SEE
AS THE BILL PROGRESSES THAT SOME
OF THE ISSUES RAISED HERE CAN BE
ADDRESSED THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE CENTER ARCHULETA.
YES.
ONCE AGAIN SENATOR JIM ED YOU'VE
DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB AND I
APPRECIATE.
WHICH AT THE I'VE I'VE GOT
COLLEGES IN IN MY AREA AND AND
OF COURSE THE SHOOTINGS IN.
GOD FORBID WHAT WHAT COULD
HAPPEN IN YOUR AREAS FIRES AND
SO ON BUT BUT AND I'M WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE OPPOSITION
DISSEMINATING THE INFORMATION IN
IN THE NUMBER SIX I SEE THE THE
INFORMATION CAN BE AND ON THE
WEBSITE.
IS THAT NECESSARY AND CAN WE HOW
CAN WE WORK AROUND THAT WELL THE
GOAL AS THE BILL'S INDICATES
THAT THE INFORMATION IS
AGGREGATED SO THE DESIGN IS NOT
TO EXPOSE ANY COMPANY.
OR ANY SPECIFIC AREA TO
POTENTIAL.
THREAT.
THE GOAL IS TO TRY TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM WORK BETTER AND SO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY ASPECTS OF REALLY
WITHIN THE SYSTEM ITSELF AND NOT
ANY PARTICULAR COMPANY OR ANY
PARTICULAR LOCATION SO I'M.
COURSE HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING
TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL BECAUSE THE
GOAL IS TO HAVE REDUNDANCY TO
HAVE AS MANY DIFFERENTWAYS TO
WARN PEOPLE AS WE CAN TO MAKE
IT AS ACCURATE AS POSSIBLE AND
TO MAKE SURE IT'S CONSISTENT SO
THAT.
WHEN SOME PEOPLE GET A LOCAL
WARNING AND SOME PEOPLE DON'T WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHY THAT IS
THAT THAT ISN'T HAPPENING?
BY AGGREGATING THE INFORMATION
NOT DESEGREGAING WE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE IDENTIFYING A
PARTICULAR COMPANY OR PROCESS
THAT MAY BE --
IN NEED OF IMPROVEMENT IT'S THE
OVERALL VIEW OF HOW WE MAKE THE
SYSTEM BETTER SO WE CAN HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION ON THAT --
AS FAR AS THE ONE OTHER.
QUESTION ON WEBSITE AND THE
WEBSITE RIGHT --
AGAIN THE INFORMATION IS NOT.
SUPPOSED TO BE SPECIFIC.
SO THAT IT COULD BE USED IN AN
ADVERSE WAY --
BY.
TERRORISTS OR WHAT OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES MIGHT EXIST IN
TODAY'S TECHNOLOGY WORLD OR IN
VIOLATION OF PRIVACY ISSUE SO
AGAIN HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON THAT.
THE GOAL IS TO GET REDUNDANCY.
THERE WAS MANY DIFFERENT OPTIONS
AS POSSIBLE TO MAKE THEM
CONSISTENT TO MAKE THEM AFFECT
THEM TO MAKE THEM.
AS EARLY AND AS CLEAR AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
RESPOND AND BE SAFE THAT IS THE
GOAL SO AGAIN I'M HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT AS WELL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CENTER BARGES.
THE VICE CHAIRMAN.
OF I THINK YOU ALREADY ADDRESSED --
MOST OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
POSED TO YOU BUT I FEEL
OBLIGATED BECAUSE THERE WERE
SOME FAIRLY COMPELLING POINTS ON
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP BY AN OF
FOLKS THAT --
HAD CONCERNS WITH IF.
SECTIONS FOUR AND FIVE WERE
REVISED TO THEIR SATISFACTION
WITH THIS STILL IN YOUR OPINION.
MOVE -- THIS --
SAFETY SYSTEM --
TOWARD --
IMPROVED VIABLE STATE.
WELL IT'S HARD TO SAY WHAT THE
FINAL SATISFACTION ELEMENT IS SO
I CAN CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THEM TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT WERE ARTICULATED ONE
OF THEM.
THE P. YOU SEE VERSUS THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES RIGHT NOW
NOBODY THAT I KNOW WAS
PARTICULARLY HIGH ON THE PC SO
THAT MAY VERY WELL BE.
AN AVENUE TO PURSUE I'VE NO
PROBLEM HAVING THOSE DISCUSSIONS
AND SO LONG AS WE'RE ALL WORKING
IN GOOD FAITH I THINK WE CAN
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION HERE
AGAIN MY GOAL.
IS REPETITIVE SYSTEMS THAT ARE
GOING TO REACH EVERYBODY AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE GIVE THEM
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION WE A
IT IS A GREAT SYSTEM BUT IT ONLY
SEE IT IT DOESN'T MEET ALL OF
THE NEEDS.
AND AND SO WE NEED TO HAVE.
A BETTER MORE ROBUST WIRELESS
THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE IT MORE
ROBUST AND ALSO TO DEAL WITH THE
CONCERNS.
THAT THEY HAVE ABOUT THE OR THAT
WERE ARTICULATED HERE TODAY OVER
THOSE SECTIONS MAYBE I'LL POSE
MY QUESTION TO MR DEVINE YOU
BROUGHT UP BUT AS YOUR THIRD
POINT --
CONFIDENTIALITY MAINTAINING.
THE INTEGRITY OF PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION OR NATIONAL SECURITY
CONCERNS WITHIN THE GRID THE
FRAMEWORK OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS --
CAN YOU EXPAND A LITTLE BIT ON
HOW YOU WOULD WORK WITH --
THE MAKER OF THIS ITEM TO
PROTECT ALL INFORMATION THAT YOU
DEEM SENSITIVE.
FIRST OFF WE'D BE DELIGHTED TO
WORK WITH THE SENATOR ON THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
AND THE IT WE ALREADY HAVE TODAY
PRACTICE WITH --
AGENCIES WHERE THEY DO ASK FOR
AND DO RECEIVE HIGHLY
PROPRIETARY AND CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION HOMELAND SECURITY
AND NETWORK SECURITY ISSUES THAT
WE PROVIDE TO THE STATE
GOVERNMENT WOULD MAKE THOSE
REPORTS AVAILABLE.
AND THEY'RE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL
AND THAT IS HONORED AND AS LONG
AS THAT'S BUILT INTO THE BILL --
THAT WOULD ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
HOWEVER I IF I MAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN ONE OTHER OBSERVATION.
THE DATA THIS BILL ASKS FOR ESOS
TO GIVE WHETHER IT'S TO P. YOU
SEE HERE --
YES AND BY THE WAY THANK YOU FOR
CAN.
WE DO NOT WORTH THE DISCUSSION.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE DATA.
IT IS INITIATED BY LOCAL
RESPONDERS.
CITIES COUNTIES OR DESIGNEES.
SO WHEN THAT DATA GOES ACROSS
THE NETWORK.
WE HAVEN'T TOUCHED IT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT SENSE.
WE DON'T WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE
ANY DATA THAT WE COULD SUBMIT
HERE SO THE CONCERN WE HAVE IS A
STATUTE REQUIRING US TO GIVES
GOVERNMENT DATA.
WHEN IN FACT WE DON'T COLLECT
THE DATA?
SO THAT IS A FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE
THAT -- AND
I MIGHT ADD THAT WAS THE OTHER
THING IS THE FACT THAT THE
SYSTEM WORKS PRETTY DARN WELL
AND ALERTS DO GO OUT.
AND LET ME STOP THERE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ARE -- ALL
THE ALL THE ALL FINISH WITH THIS
THAT -- FROM
NINETEEN THE THREE SIXTY WHICH I
THINK MAY HAVE --
ADDRESS ONE OF THE CONCERNS THAT
THE MAKER THE ITEM HAD PUT
FORWARD AND ON NOT ENOUGH
INFORMATION.
THE RESPONSIVENESS IN THE
ABILITY TO RESPOND THAT'S TO BE
DETERMINED BUT ULTIMATELY.
I WANNA MAKE CERTAIN THAT --
BY WILL TO ME BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND IN MY PREVIOUS
CAPACITY IS SUPERVISOR WE ARE
SHOOTING A DOWNTOWN FRESNO.
AND I WAS --
TASKED WITH THE CREATING
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PROTOCOLS
WITHIN THE COUNTING I WAS
FLABBERGASTED.
AND HOW ILL EQUIPPED WE WERE TO
HANDLE A SITUATION LIKE THAT.
AND IMMEDIATELY BEGAN
INSTITUTING --
REFORMS ON DONE TOWARD IMPROVING
THAT.
PUBLIC AS WELL AS EMPLOYEE
SAFETY -- SO
I APPRECIATE THE MAKER THIS ITEM
MOVING THIS FORWARD I THINK.
GIVEN WHAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED
THIS IS THE RIGHT PATH AS LONG
AS WE FIND A WAY THAT PROTECTS
INFORMATION THAT CREATES PREPARE
THE DOES NOT UNFAIRLY CREE
PRESUMPTIONS WITHIN THE INDUSTRY.
ALL THAT CAN BE WORKED AROUND
THEN I THINK THERE'S A PATH
FORWARD AS LONG AS THE
PREVAILING PARTIES --
COME TO AGREEMENT [inaudible]
BETTER GALGIANI.
I HAD A COMMENT AND THEN I HAD A
QUESTION IN MY OWN HOME COUNTY I
RECEIVE AN EMERGENCY TEXT ALERT
AND I ALSO RECEIVE AN EMAIL.
AND I THINK IT WORKS WONDERFUL
WHEN I'M OUT ON MISTER DEVINE
MENTIONED THAT THAT WE A SYSTEM
HAS A CAPTURE THE CAPTURE YOUR
WIRELESS DEVICE EVEN WHEN YOU'RE
VISITING AN AREA.
I WAS WITH SENATOR NIELSEN IN
PARADISE SHORTLY AFTER THE FIRES
WHEN THEY HAD THE FLOOD WATCH
WARNING.
AND I RECEIVED AN ALERT I
ASSUMED IT WAS A TAXED AND SO I
WENT TO OPEN IT AND IT
DISAPPEARED.
I THINK IT DISAPPEARED AND THEN
I I GOT ANOTHER ALERT ON MY
OTHER CELL PHONE I COULD HEAR
THAT OTHER MEMBERS WHO ARE
VISITING --
ALSO STARTED GETTING ALL OF
THEIR OTHER TO THE SAME TIME.
MY QUESTION IS WHEN YOU REFER TO
THE ONE AND DONE.
IS THAT WHEN IT'S AN ALERT ON
YOUR CELL PHONE AND THEN IT GOES
AWAY WHAT IS ONE AND DONE.
IF I USE THAT LANGUAGE --
I THINK IT WAS --
IT WAS SOMEBODY ELSE.
IN TERMS OF THE ONE AND DONE
TYPE MESSAGE WE ARE MESSAGES ARE
TRANSMITTED ONCE BY THE CARRIERS
THEY DO A VERY GOOD JOB OF THIS
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
PHONES ARE RECEIVING THE SIGNAL
CORRECTLY.
THOSE MESSAGES COME UP.
VERY QUICLY.
THEY APPEAR ON THE DISPLAY
SCREEN.
HOWEVER AS YOU DISCOVERED WHEN
YOU TRIED TO OPEN THE MESSAGE
THINKING IT WAS A CONVENTIONAL
TAXED IT CLEARED IT FROM THE
DEVICES MEMORY.
THE DEVICES DO NOT SAVE THESE
MESSAGES AND THAT'S WHERE THE
THE COLLOQUIALISM ONE AND DONE
HAS COME TO REFER TO WE A
MESSAGES.
I SEE SO I WAS RIGHT ABOUT THAT --
I CAN SEE WHERE I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS BILL IS GOING TO ADDRESS
THAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
SCIENCE WELL ENOUGH BUT I WOULD
THINK THAT.
A LIKE IN MY TO HERE IS THE TEXT
WHERE YOU CAN ACTUALLY OPEN IT
AND SEE IT. FOR ME IT WENT AWAY
SO FAST THAT I WASN'T SURE WHAT
IT WAS SO --
ANYWAY THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING
THAT [inaudible]
SENATOR ALLEN.
YEAH AND I BY POTS AS IF THIS IS
BEEN RAISED BEFORE I'M IN
RESPECT FOR THE AD WITH NATURIST
OR SAYS.
I NOTICED IN THE OPPOSITION.
PIECE OF THE NOW SAYS A TALKED
ABOUT DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE FOUNDIN THIS BILL
CONTRAVENE CLEAR FEDERAL
GUIDANCE.
ON THE PRISON CONFIDENTIALITY
THAT INFORMATION.
AS WELL AS INDUSTRY BACK BEST
PRACTICES AND I WANTED TO KIND
OF ASK EVERYBODY ABOUT THE
FEDERALISM ISSUES HERE THE
POTENTIAL TENSION BETWEEN THIS
BILL AND FEDERAL LAW AND GET.
PERSPECTIVES ON THAT.
I DON'T THINK THERE THERE IS A
IS A FEDERAL ISSUE HERE --
OF CONCERN WE ARE TRYING AND
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING THIS
THAT THE GOAL IS TO AGGREGATE
THE INFORMATION SO THAT THERE'S
NO.
ABILITY TO AYE TO SPEAK TO
IDENTIFY WITH SPECIFICITY THE
COMPANY WHERE THE PROBLEM IS TO
IT ANYTHING THAT'S GOING
UNDERMINE ISSUES OF GENUINE
NATIONAL CONCERTS.
CONCERN OR NATIONAL SECURITY
THAT'S WHY TO AGGREGATED AND
WE'RE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO KEEP
WORKING.
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO TO CREATE.
THE ASSURANCES OR TO CREATE A
SYSTEM OF THIS INFORMATION IS
EACH ASCERTAINABLE. FOR PURPOSES
THAT WOULD IN ANY WAY DAMAGE THE
COMPANY ITSELF --
OR NATIONAL SECURITY THE GOAL IS.
AGAIN REDUNDANCY HERE THE GOAL
IS TO HAVE AS MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS TO WARN PEOPLE AS A
POSSIBLE --
AND IT AT THE SAME TIME TO
PROTECT THE VARIOUS SYSTEMS THAT
EXISTS NO ONE WANTS UNDERMINE
THE SYSTEMS WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE
WORKING.
AS BEST AS THEY CAN AND THAT'S
WHY I'M GETTING THIS GENERAL
DATA TO SEE WHY IT IS THAT SOME
PEOPLE GET THE MESSAGES AND SOME
PEOPLE DO NOT AND THAT IS A FACT.
SO TO IMPROVE THE SYSTEM --
WORKING WITH THE THE VARIOUS
WIRELESS COMPANIES WHO IN
TODAY'S WORLD ARE REALLY
BECOMING MORE AND MORE A
CRITICAL PLAYER IN THIS WARNING
SYSTEM TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
THAT'S THE GOAL THAT SORT OF THE
DYNAMIC WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND
I THINK.
AGAIN HAPPY TO KEEP CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS --
TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL.
OKAY RISK CROSSING IN THE CHURCH
HERE YEAH --
A COUPLE THINGS --
ON THE FEDERAL ISSUE IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING AND WE SHOULD ALL
LOOK AT IT MORE CLOSELY THAT THE
FEDERAL STORED COMMUNICATIONS
ACT WHICH USC CHAPTER. ONE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN A ONE TO
TWENTY SEVEN TWELVE PROHIBITS
WIRELESS CARRIERS FROM
DISCLOSING CUSTOMER INFORMATION
INCLUDING NAMES ADDRESSES AND
PHONE NUMBERS TO ANY
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY.
WITHOUT APPROPRIATE LEGAL
PROCESS AND THAT ACTUALLY THE
BASIS OF THAT.
IS -- WAY
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT ONCE YOU
KNOW IT'S SORT OF LIKE THE TV
SHOWS THAT THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT
HAPPENS --
YOU KNOW JUST SAY WHAT TYPE I
CAN PAYING HIM SO IF YOU'RE
GONNA THE THE SOMEBODY HAS A HAS
BEEN A KIDNAP.
AND THE LAW ENFORCEMENT SAYS
OKAY I WANT THAT NUMBER TO
PAYING IT --
ONLY AN EXIGENCY ARKHAM STANCES
CAN THEY GET THAT NUMBER WITHOUT
LEGAL PROCESS SO THAT'S OUR
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
THAT KIND OF A POPPING UP
AGAINST THAT CENTER JACKSON WELL
I APPRECIATE THAT BUT AGAIN.
THE THE BILL IS VERY SPECIFIC AS
TO THE LIMITATIONS OF THE USE OF
THIS INFORMATION ONLY FOR
EMERGENCY PURPOSES AND I WOULD.
ARGUE THAT LEGAL PROCESS IS
PASSING LEGISLATION THAT CREATES
THAT ABILITY BUT LIMITED BECAUSE
I THINK THE CONCERNS HAVE TO DO
WITH WHETHER OR NOT THAT
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE USED.
FOR OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
REQUIREMENTS AND NACHOS FOR THE
LIMITED PURPOSE LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS TASKED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO DO THAT FIRST
RESPONSE.
IN CASES OF EMERGENCY THAT IS
THEIR JOB.
AND THIS LEGISLATION SPECIFIES
AND LIMITS THEIR ABILITY TO USE
THAT INFORMATION TO OUR WHICH
MAYBE IT'S MAYBE IT'S A GOOD
COURT CASE WILL HAVE SOME FUN
OVERNIGHT.
I THINK RIGHT NOW THAT THAT IS
THE LIMITATION A AND IT'S VERY
SPECIFIC.
AS TO WHAT CAN BE DONE WITH IT I
THINK THE LEGAL PROCESS ARE
TALKING ABOUT IS A SEARCH
WARRANT OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT --
THAT MAY BE AND THAT'S WHY C.
ALERTS WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
SERVING PROCESS SERVING A
WARRANT MAKING AN ARREST.
IT'S SIMPLY TO DEAL WITH THIS
ONE SPECIFIC RESPONSIBILITY THAT
pCALIFORNIA GIVEN TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WHETHER IT'S A THE VICTIM
SENDING OUT THAT GETTING THAT
INFORMATION AND AGAIN --
THIS MAY BE A PHILOSOPHICAL
DISCUSSION BUT I THINK GIVEN THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WE ALREADY DID
THIS WITH THIS BE A TWENTY ONE
AND I DON'T THINK WE'VE SEEN ANY
LAWSUITS THUS FAR.
I SUSPECT THAT NO ONE REALLY
WANTS TO BRING THOSE LOSSES
BECAUSE YOU KNOW EIGHTEEN T. AND
AND ALL OF THESE WIRELESS
COMPANIES THEY DO BUSINESS HERE
CALIFORNIA THEY MAKE A LOT OF
MONEY HERE IN CALIFORNIA THEY
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I WOULD THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY WOULD WANT
TO PERFECT.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THOSE
CUSTOMERS IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THE COMMUNITIES THAT PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT INCOME TO THE
COMPANIES GO THROUGH OUT SO I I
I SEE THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO ALL WORK TOGETHER. TO
PROTECT THOSE CONCERNS THAT THE
COMPANIES MIGHT HAVE ABOUT TRADE
SECRETS OR OTHER THINGS OF THAT
SORT WHICH WERE HAPPY TO DO.
BUT TO TO TRY TO IMPROVE OUR
WARNING SYSTEMS TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY THE PEOPLE OF
OUR STATE.
OUR MISTER MISTER DEVINE DID YOU
WANT TO WEIGH IN ON THIS UP I
JUST WANTED TO ANSWER THE OTHER
HALF OF OF SENATOR ALLEN'S
QUESTION IF YOU LOOK AT PAGE
NINE SECTION FOR THE BILL.
PARAGRAPH FEE IT GOES ON TO READ
FOR PURPOSES OF THIS SECTION THE
COMMISSION MAY REQUIRE A TELECOM
PROVIDER TO COLLECT AND FORWARD
TO THE COMMISSION ANY RELEVANT
INFORMATION.
AND PURSUANT TO EXISTING
AUTHORITY MAKE THIS INFORMATION
PUBLIC.
EXCEPT THE INFORMATION GENERATED
OR OBTAINED PURSUANT TO
SUBDIVISION BE EXTRA SO IT GIVES
THE COMMISSION THE AUTHORITY
AUTOMATIC AUTHORITY TO DECIDE
THE INFORMATION WE SUBMIT IS
PUBLIC.
UNLESS WE CAN PERSUADE THEM.
THAT IT SHOULD REMAIN
CONFIDENTIAL THAT IS A REVERSE
OF THE HISTORY THAT HAS EXISTED
FOR THIS INDUSTRY.
AND PARTICULARLY AROUND HOMELAND
SECURITY AND NETWORK SECURITY
ISSUES AT THE COMMISSION IT IS
ALWAYS CONFIDENTIAL AND IT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO AFFIRMATIVELY TAKE
A VOTE TO REMOVE THAT
CONFIDENTIALITY IN THIS INSTANCE
IT'S AUTOMATICALLY PUBLIC WHEN
YOU SUBMIT IT.
AND THEY WOULD HAVE TO ACTIVELY
MAKE IT CONFIDENTIAL AFTER THE
FACT SO THAT IS OUR CONCERN ON
THE RELEASE OF NETWORK
INFORMATION WHETHER IT'S THE P.
UC OR CALLAWAY S..
IF I MIGHT JUST SAY IT.
IT'S SPECIFICALLY SECURITY
INFORMATION IS EXCLUDED FROM ANY
PUBLIC.
INFORMATION AND AGAIN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE.
ON THIS ISSUE WE THESE CONCERNS
MUCH APPRECIATED --
HAVE HAVEN'T BEEN VETTED.
BUT AGAIN THE BASIC PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL IS TO IMPROVE THE
SYSTEMS IT'S TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO CREATE THAT.
REDUNDANCY TO BETTER TARGET.
BECAUSE WE A DOZEN TO THAT AS
WELL.
AND TO PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INNER ACT.
IN OTHERWISE BE MORE PREPARED TO
RESPOND TO THESE EMERGENCY SO WE
WILL ARE I'M HAPPY TO KEEP
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE --
I DON'T WANT TO SEE ROAD BLOCK
AFTER ROADBLOCK AFTER WORLD
BLOCK I DON'T THINK WE WILL
BECAUSE AS I MENTIONED I THINK
THAT THE WIRELESS COMPANIES
RECOGNIZE THEY DO HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IN THAT SPIRIT.
OF WORKING TOGETHER --
I WHICH IS SIMPLY CLOSE AND AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THE ISSUE.
YOU HAVE A FOLLOW UP SENATOR
ALLEN ARE TIGHT I IT IS KIND OF
AND THE DIE I LOVE SEEING THE
KIND OF THE THE THE MIX OF
PLAYERS --
IN IN NEW YORK STRONG SUPPORT OF
BIG DATA COLLECTION --
FROM THE TECH INDUSTRY SO EVENT
BUT IT BUT IT'S BEEN A IT I
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE DOING IT
I'M IS THERE'S A THERE'S A
THERE'S A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE
HERE BUT THEY'RE ALSO OUR SERIES
OF PRIVACY ISSUES THAT YOU KNOW
IN THOSE WELL AND THOSE ADDRESS.
BUT I KNOW YOUR PASSION ABOUT
THEIR SPECIFIC A TWENTY ONE
SPECIFICALLY LIMITS THIS
INFORMATION FOR EMERGENCY
NOTIFICATION ONLY WHEN THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
COMMUNITY IS AT RISK.
RAN THIS INFORMATION SHOULD BE
COLLECTED BUT ONLY FOR THAT
PURPOSE AND I HOPEFULLY YOU MAKE
THAT IF WE CAN MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION WHETHER TECH
COMPANIES ARE SELLING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE THE TIME.
THE THE OVULATION CYCLES OF
WOMEN IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE GOING TO
LET PEOPLE KNOW THEY GOT TO GET
OUT.
AND WHERE THEY NEED TO GO TO GET
OUT OF HARM'S WAY BUT ONE OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT CAME UP AT ARE
YOU JUDICIARY HEARING WAS NOT
JUST THE THIRD THE COGNIZANT.
SELLING OF INFORMATION BUT THE
VULNERABILITY.
OF A LOT OF THESE COMPANIES TO
HACKING AND AND AND AND THE AND
THE REST.
AND SO --
YOU WE CAN BE VERY SPECIFIC
ABOUT PUTTING IN RULES THAT
WOULD PREVENT THEM FROM SELLING
INFORMATION HI BUT BUT THERE'S
ALSO.
KIND OF SECURITY ISSUES
INVOLVING.
NUMBER BACKING VULNERABILITIES
THAT ARE OUT THERE SO.
AS ANOTHER --
IS ANOTHER CONCERN THAT I KNOW
YOU CARE ABOUT I MEAN I THIS IS
THIS IS WHAT MAKES THIS WORK SO
INTERESTING.
HI I'M SURE WE CAN CAN DISCUSS
THOSE AS WELL IT'S NOT AN ISSUE
I'VE HEARD HERE IT'S NOT AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT AT THIS POINT IN
TIME -- I
GUESS ANYTHING COULD BE HACKED
AND THAT IS A SERIOUS CONCERN
BUT AT THIS POINT TIME WE'RE
FOCUSING ON WHAT TO DO TO GIVE
GREATER WARNINGS TO PEOPLE IN
EMERGENCIES WE KEEP SEEING THEM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN YOUR DISTRICT AS
WELL.
AND WHAT DO WE DO TO GIVE PEOPLE
A CHANCE TO GET OUT SAFELY SO
THAT THEY'RE NOT ANOTHER ONE OF
THE STATISTICS OF THE HUNDRED
OVER HUNDRED TWENTY PEOPLE WERE
KILLED IN THESE FIRES THE TWENTY
THREE PEOPLE KILLED IN MY
DISTRICT FROM THE DEBRIS FLOW
THAT OCCURRED.
RIGHT AFTER FIR AND IT GOES ON
AND ON CHANGES WE SEE THE
INTENSITY OF THE WEATHER
PATTERNS CREATING GREATER AND
GREATER RISK TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT A STEP UP.
IN THIS IS ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
WE CAN DO THAT AND SO AGAIN
WORKING TO CREATE THE
PROTECTIONS WE NEED WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME PROTECTING.
A LEGITIMATE CONCERNS OF
INDUSTRY ARE PART OF WHAT WE'RE
HOPING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE.
I WHICH I SENATOR RUBIO FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR HILL.
THANK YOU TERMS ARE WILL FIRST
OF ALL LET ME THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING UP THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE CLEARLY YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE PASSIONATE
ABOUT AND I AM AWARE OF ALL THAT
A TRAGEDY THAT OCCURRED IN YOUR
COMMUNITY SO I CAN SEE THE
PASSION FOR IT.
BUT I DO ALONG THE LINES OF
MISTER ALLEN I DO SEE A LITTLE
BIT OF DISCONNECT IN TERMS OF
THE ISSUES RAISED HERE AND THE
ABILITY FOR THE COMPANIES TO
COLLECTED DATA IF I HEARD MR
DOING CORRECTLY THREE THREE
TIMES THEY DO NOT COLLECT.
DATA DIRECTLY AND SELL I JUST
HOPE THAT AND I THINK I HEARD
YOU SAY THAT YOU HAVE THE
WILLINGNESS TO IN GOOD FAITH SIT
DOWN AND FIGURE OUT THOSE.
THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
TO STEP UP BUT WE HAVE TO DO IT
RIGHT AND SO I APPRECIATE YOU
WILL NEED TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THINK WHICH ARE.
THANK YOU SIR RUBIO SENATOR HILL.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR FUTURE
AND AND IT'S WE CAN I'VE HAD.
LONG DISCUSSIONS OVER THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MATERIAL OF
OF OF INFORMATION AT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ESPECIALLY.
AND AS WE'VE SEEN HISTORICALLY
IT IS.
SPECIFIED IS CONFIDENTIAL AND
LET'S AND THEN IT GOES TO THE
WITH.
THE PROBLEM THAT WE'VE HAD WITH
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
IS GETTING THE INFORMATION
BECAUSE IT IS ALL CONFIDENTIAL
AND THERE'S SOME VERY STRICT
RULES AROUND RELATION OF THAT.
I THINK IT MAY BE TIME TO CHANGE
THAT AND ALLOW INFORMATION TO BE --
NON CONFIDENTIAL UNLESS IT CAN
BE SHOWN AND PROVED THAT IT
SHOULD BE CONFIDENTIAL I THINK
IT MAY BE TIME TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION THE FUTURE GOING TO
REVERSE THAT PARADIGM.
THAT WE'VE SEEN AT THE P. YOU
SEE BECAUSE IT IS --
IT'S IT.
IT'S BEEN PROBLEMATIC IN A
NUMBER OF AREAS SO IF TO STOP IT
THAT'S FOR TIME FOR CONVERSATION
FOR ANOTHER DAY.
BUT TO THANK YOU MISTER TO FIND
THANK YOU FOR THE LEGISLATION.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS [inaudible]
BOB JUST.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU MY VOTE TODAY.
AS YOU KNOW I LIVE IN A WILD
FIRE AREA JUST LIKE YOU AND WE
NEED TO PROTECT OUR OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
OTHERS SEEMS TO BE SOME SOME
HURDLES FEET ACROSS AND YOU'VE
MADE A PLEASURE TODAY TO WORK
WITH OPPOSITION AND HOPEFULLY WE
COME UP WITH THE SYSTEM THAT
THAT.
PROTECTS ALL SO WITH THAT PLEASE
CLOSE HEARING OPPORTUNITY --
PART OF THE WHOLE INTERESTING
PROCESS WE HAVE IS THEY'LL BE A
NUMBER OF STEPS TO BE TAKEN THIS
IS THE FIRST I'M HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION AGAIN THE
GOAL I THINK IT'S CLEAR I THINK
WE FULLY ALL AGREE THAT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT.
ONE SOMETIMES THE DEVIL'S IN THE
DETAILS AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO
KEEP WORKING ON THOSE DETAILS.
WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
NEW APPROVED.
A MOVE BY CENTER GALGIANI SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO RULES TO BE RE REFER TO
ENERGY AND UTILITY TELLY SENT
OUT I THINK MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP HERE WILL
BE DISCUSSED IN THAT NEXT
COMMITTEE.
FILE ITEM THREE SB FORTY SIX
MOTION IS TO PASS TO RULES
COMMITTEE DODD.
WILK HI WELL I ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D FORGES
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL.
HELLO I WAS SO [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER AYE. SEVEN KEEP IT UP.
YES SEVEN VOTE SO WE WILL KEEP
IT OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD
ON THANK YOU CENTER WORLD THANK
YOU MEMBERS.
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO FILE ITEM
FIVE SENATOR WIENER.
SB [inaudible]
FIFTY EIGHT RIGHT.
THE LAKERS Là.
TWO HEY HOW ARE
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK.
YEAH.
SO BEFORE WE START DO YOU I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE FOUR SPEAKERS.
AT TWO THIRTY YOU GOT IT YOU
HAVE TO OKAY.
BECAUSE I THOUGHT WE SIGNED OFF
ON FOR BUT THAT'S FINE TUESDAY.
WE HAVE TWO CHOICES GOOD.
ALL I SEE OKAY WELL CENTER
WIENER PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
FOR THERE WILL BE A COUPLE OF
OPPOSITION SPEAKERS IN FRONT OF
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES --
FOR HEARING THIS BILL TODAY
SENATE BILL --
FIFTY EIGHT I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE.
FOR OUR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSE THE BILL --
COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL.
FIFTY EIGHT IS A LOCAL CONTROL
BILL -- IT
GIVES LOCAL.
A COMMUNITIES THE ABILITY TO
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES.
WHETHER TO EXTEND THEIR NIGHT
LIKE OURS.
HI THIS IS A FIVE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM.
IN TEN CITIES WHO HAVE REQUESTED
TO BE A PART OF THE PILOT
PROGRAM.
SERVICES TO REPEAT THAT IT IS A
PILOT PROGRAM SO WE CAN SEE HOW
IT WORKS.
THAT THEIR PROBLEMS WE DON'T
HAVE TO CONTINUE IT IT WORKS
WELL WE CAN CONTINUE IT.
OMITTED TO TEN CITIES.
WHO HAVE REQUESTED TO BE?
IN THE BILL.
THE BILL IS ALMOST EXACTLY THE
SAME BILL --
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED LAST YEAR
AND BIPARTISAN MANNER --
TO CREATE THIS PILOT PROGRAM THE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT THIS YEAR AND
ADDITION TO THE NINE CITIES FROM
LAST YEAR --
THE CITY OF FRESNO --
AGAIN SHOWING BI PARTISANSHIP
INCLUDED IN THE BILL --
AND WE HAVE INCLUDED A FRESNO
[inaudible]
ON SO BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY --
ABOUT GIVING COMMUNITIES
FLEXIBILITY. FOR ABOUT A HUNDRED
YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A
STATEWIDE --
BLANKET --
AND TONIGHT LIKE OURS --
TO ALCOHOL SERVICE AT OUR BARS
OR NIGHTCLUBS --
AT TWO AM WHETHER YOU ARE IN A
SMALL RURAL TOWN.
OR WHETHER YOU ARE IN DOWNTOWN
SAN FRANCISCO OR DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES --
IT HOSTAGES AND AT TWO AM NO
FLEXIBILITY NO MATTER WHAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE THESE
TEN CITIES WITH THE ABILITY TO
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES.
WHETHER TO STAY WITH THE TWO I
AM OR GO EARLIER BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT FLEXIBILITY. FOR TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO GO LATER.
NO CITY WILL BE REQUIRED I AM.
THIS BILL IN AND OF ITSELF DOES
NOT AUTOMATICALLY CHANGE
ANYTHING.
ALL IT DOES IS GIVE CITIES
PERMISSION TO MAKE THAT DECISION
LOCALLY RECOGNIZING THAT NIGHT
LIFE IS DIFFERENT.
IN DIFFERENT CITIES IF THE CITY
DOES NOT ACT.
DâN THE RULES DON'T CHANGE THEN
THE SAME TWO AM CLOSING TIME.
APPLIES IN THOSE CITIES.
THE BILL APPLIES TO BARS
RESTAURANTS NIGHTCLUBS IT DOES
NOT APPLY TO LIQUOR STORES --
SO ARE.
I WANT TO ALSO JUST MENTION THAT.
OUR CURRENT RIGID TWO AM CLOSING
TIME.
IS NOT IN LINE WITH OTHER STATES.
MORE THAN A DOZEN OTHER STATES
ALLOW ALCOHOL SERVICE PAST TWO
AM.
WHAT CALIFORNIA WE'RE POSE IN
THIS BILL IS NOT SOME SORT OF
RADICAL DEPARTURE RED STATES
BLUE STATES?
ALL SORTS OF STATES ALLOW LATER
CLOSING TIME AND THE WORLD
HASN'T ENDED IN THOSE STATES IT
WORKS JUST FINE.
MY LIFE IS A MAJOR ECONOMIC
DRIVER IN CALIFORNIA IT IS A
HUGE EMPLOYER --
IT IS A HUGE --
SOURCE OF TAX REVENUE --
IT'S A HUGE SOURCE OF ECONOMIC
NOW PARTICULARLY IN OUR MAJOR
CITIES ARE TOURIST CENTERS
CALIFORNIA HAS PLACED ITSELF AT
A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE --
BY HAVING --
WHITE IN THE BIG SCHEME OF
THINGS IS AN EARLY CLOSING TIME --
DESTROYED CLOSING TIME ALSO DOES
NOT RECOGNIZE THAT NOT EVERYONE
WORKS AND NINE TO FIVE JOB AND
GOES TO BED AT TEN OR ELEVEN AT
NIGHT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
DON'T EVEN GET OFF WORK.
UNTIL MIDNIGHT AND WE BASICALLY
TOLD THOSE PEOPLE YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO GO OUT.
BECAUSE BY THE TIME THEY GET
HOME CHANGE GO OUT AGAIN IT'S
ALREADY ONE THIRTY AND THINGS
ARE WINDING DOWN.
SO THIS BILL ALIGNS US WITH BEST
PRACTICES IN OTHER STATES.
THE BILL HAS SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
SAFETY SAFEGUARDS AND IT WE
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT THIS
IS OUR THIRD --
TIME AT THE RODEO ON THIS THE
GOVERNOR VETOED THE BILL LAST
YEAR.
WE NOW HAVE A NEW GOVERNOR
SERVER TRYING AGAIN --
WE WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT --
TO PUT GUARD RAILS ON THE BILL.
THIS IS IN A SITUATION WORK CITY
CAN TO SAY IF A CITY THE SIZE
THAT IT MIGHT WANT TO DO IT.
THE CITY FIRST HAS TO CONVENE A
COMMUNITY TASK FORCE TO GO OVER
THE ISSUE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THAT TASK FORCE MUST INCLUDE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND C. H.
P. TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS. FIVE
THE CITY COUNCIL ALSO HAS TO
FORMULATE A PUBLIC SAFETY PLAN.
AND THE TRANSPORTATION PLAN TO
ENSURE SAFETY.
BY THE CITY COUNCIL THEN HAS TO
PASS AN ORDINANCE BASED ON THOSE
PLANS.
AND THAT PLAN THAT GETS
SUBMITTED TO THE ABC FOR REVIEW
TO MAKE SURE THAT A COMPLY.
AND ONCE A. B. C. CERTIFIES THAT
THEY'VE DONE WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO.
THAT'S JUST THE FIRST STEP
BECAUSE THE NEXT STEP IS THAT
ANY ESTABLISHMENT THAT WANTS TO
EXTEND ITS HOURS.
HAS TO THEN APPLY TO BBC FOR
THAT EXTENSION.
THE SAME WAY THAT YOU WOULD
APPLY FOR A LIQUOR LICENSE YOU
HAVE TO APPLY THEY DO AN
INVESTIGATION NEIGHBORS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT EXPRESS
OBJECTIONS ARE SUPPORT.
THERE IS AN APPEAL PROCESS.
SO THIS IS A VERY VERY ORIENTED
APPROACH.
IN ADDITION CITIES ARE NOT
REQUIRED SIGN ON SWITCH OFF
SWITCH -- I
I DOUBT THAT ANY CITY WOULD
APPLY THIS TO THE WHOLE CITY
THEY KIND OF THEY WANT BUT IT'S
UNLIKELY.
A CITY CAN LIMITED TO ONE ST.
OR ONE NEIGHBORHOOD OR
ENTERTAINMENT ZONE I CITY CAN
SAY WE'RE GOING TO DO IT SEVEN
NIGHTS A WEEK WERE ONLY DOING A
FRIDAY AND SATURDAY NIGHTS OR A
CITY CAN SAY WE'RE ONLY DOING
THIS ONE OR TWO NIGHTS A YEAR.
FOR SPECIAL EVENTS --
SO CITIES WILL HAVE ENORMOUS
FLEXIBILITY IN DECIDING.
WHETHER IT MAKES SENSE AND IF SO.
IN WHAT FORM.
HI I DO WANT TO ADDRESS BECAUSE
I KNOW --
EVERY TIME WE RAISES BUILDERS
DISCUSSION ABOUT --
DRUNK DRIVING ABOUT THE WISE AND
AS I HAVE MENTIONED THIS TO THIS
COMMITTEE --
BOTH IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN I WAS HERE
ON THIS IS A VERY PERSONAL ISSUE
FOR ME BECAUSE WHEN I WAS A
CHILD IN NINETEEN SEVENTIES MY
AUNT.
MY FATHER'S ONLY SISTER WAS
KILLED BY A DRUNK DRIVER.
AND THIS IS DURING THE TIME
PERIOD ONE LAWS AROUND DRUNK
DRIVING WERE INADEQUATE --
THERE WERE NO THEY'RE ALMOST NO
CONSEQUENCES ARE FOR THIS PERSON.
AND SO THIS IS A PERSONAL ISSUE
FOR ME I'M VERY SENSITIVE TO I
WOULD NOT POSE A BILL IF I
THOUGHT IT WOULD INCREASED DRUNK
DRIVING.
AND THE REALITY IS THAT DESPITE
SOME OF THE COMMON TO HEAR FROM
OPPONENTS WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DATA THERE IS NO DATA INDICATING.
THAT LATER CLOSING TIME
INCREASES WE HAVE --
COMPARED ALL FIFTY STATES
CLOSING TIMES VERSES RATES OF
THE Y. COLLISIONS THERE IS NO
CORRELATION --
SO THERE UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO WHETHER YOU CLOSE THE
BARS AT TEN PM MIDNIGHT TO I AM
OR FOUR AM THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
WHO ARE GOING TO LEAVE TRONG AND
THEIR CAR AND AS HORRIBLE.
THEY NEED TO BE CONSEQUENCES FOR
THAT -- BUT
IT DOES NOT DEPEND ON WHEN.
THE BARS CLOSE.
SO COLLEAGUES OUT THIS IS A I I
THINK THAT THIS IS A A BILL
WHOSE TIME HAS COME. TO GIVE OUR
COMMUNITIES WHAT WERE NIGHT LIFE
IS SO IMPORTANT CULTURALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY. TO GIVE PEOPLE AN
CITIES THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
TAILOR THEIR NIGHT LIFE O THE
NEEDS OF THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TO DO AND A FIVE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM.
THAT WILL EXPIRE AFTER FIVE
YEARS IF WE DON'T EXTEND THAT WE
CAN SEE HOW IT WORKS.
AND THEN TAKE IT OUT FROM THERE --
AND THEN FINALLY I WANT TO LEAVE
YOU WITH YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
TRANSPORTATION --
EVER WHEN I FIRST STARTED GOING
OUT WHEN I WAS MUCH YOUNGER --
IT WAS YOU KNOW PEOPLE THROW
THERE ARE MANY MORE OPTIONS
TODAY IN ADDITION TO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IN SOME AREAS AND
FOUR AM BY THE WAY IS A LOT
CLOSER. TO THE OPENING OF PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS LIKE A
BAR OR AND LA METRO WHICH OPENED
EARLY IN THE MORNING. FOUR AM IS
VERY CLOSE TO WHEN THEY OPEN TWO
AM IS NOT.
BUT APART FROM THAT WE NOW HAVE
RIDE SCHERING AND IS A LOT
EASIER TO GET AROUND WITHOUT
HAVING TO DRIVE --
SO GOD COLLEAGUES --
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT --
AND WITH ME TODAY ARE BARRED NEW
IN WHO'S THE PRESIDENT CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
ASSOCIATION.
AND NICOLO DELUCA REPRESENTING
THE CITY OF OAKLAND THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THE MORNING. FOR ME THIS IS PART
OF NEWTON.
AND PRESIDENCY --
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION.
ALSO THANK YOU SORRY ALSO KNOWN
AS CAL TRAVEL IN HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SB.
FIFTY EIGHT MEMBERS OF CAL
TRAVEL TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN THE
EXPERIENCES AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE CAN BRING
TO VISITORS FROM STATE TO
CALIFORNIA.
BOTH TO MET DOMESTIC AND
INTERNATIONAL VISITORS LOVE TO
COME TO OUR STATE.
BOTH OF MY MEMBERS REYES WERE AT
A DISADVANTAGE AGAINST OTHER
DESTINATIONS CITIES BECAUSE OF
OUR TWO AM CLOSING.
IT HURTS US WHEN WE COMPETE FOR
CONVENTIONS FOR CONFERENCES FOR
OTHER POPULAR EVENTS.
PLEASE USE PILOT PROGRAM AS WAY
FOR OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
GROW THE BUSINESS IS THERE
ALREADY.
I CANNOT DRIVERS FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES IT'S ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR OTHER BUSINESSES
TO POTENTIALLY EXPAND THEIR
SERVICES. FOR EXAMPLE IF PART A
BAR RESTAURANT DOES HAVE
EXTENDED HOURS THAT COULD BE TO
OTHER BUSINESSES RELATED TO IT
LIKE SPECIALIZED LOCAL TOURS
TRANSPORTATION COMPANIES.
RESORTS ACTIVITIES --
SO OURS AS WELL.
THE UNIQUENESS AND APPEAL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES --
WILL ONLY LIKELY INCREASE.
WITH THIS IT WILL INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CONVENTIONS --
CONFERENCES AND VISITORS AND
THEREFORE OUR LOCAL REVENUES.
WE BELIEVE SB FIFTY TO BALANCE
BILL THAT WILL GIVE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE LOCAL ECONOMIES.
SO AS TOURISM'S UNITED VOICE IN
THE STATE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
CHAIRPERSON WILK MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NICOLO DELUDE HERE
BEHALF OF THE MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF
I'LL BE BRIEF --
WE THANK THE SENATOR FOR ALL
THIS WORK ON THIS TO BE ONE OF
THE PILOTS CITIES --
THE WAY THAT WE LOOK AT THIS
THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF INPUT
NEEDED TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN --
FROM OPENS POINT OF VIEW THE FOX
THEATER AREA AT THE UPTOWN
DISTRICT IS WHERE WE WOULD DO IT
THAT -- AS
YOU KNOW A LOT IT'S A GREAT
MUSIC VENUE THERE'S A UP TO
TWENTY BARS AND RESTAURANTS ARE
LOCALLY OWNED THAT COULD REALLY
BENEFIT FROM THAT REVENUE.
OBVIOUSLY PUBLIC SAFETY IS A
VERY BIG ISSUE FOR OAKLAND SO WE
DO -- WORK
WITH OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT THE
COUNTY AND AND OTHERS ON THAT.
SO ABBOTT **** THE ANSWER ANY
SPECIFIC FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
ANTI MANY HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF FRESNO WE WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR FOR INCLUDING US IS --
IN THE LIST OF CITIES FOR
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PILOT PROGRAM
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL COMPLIMENTS
ARE LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
INITIATIVES AND STILL HAS THE
RIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES TO
EXERT LOCAL CONTROLS WE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR INTRODUCING THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KATIE ME UP ON
BEHALF OF THE VA HOUSE BAD OF
COMMITTEE A INDIANS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE MY NAME IS SHARON
MEMBERS GREG HAYES ABOUT HALF OF
LEFT WERE VERY PLEASED TO
CONTRIBUTE TO REDUCTION AND
DRINKING AND DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE IN THE MARKETS WE
SERVE.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS ROSS BUCKLEY WITH
CALIFORNIA VISORS ON BEHALF OF
THE MAYOR SACRAMENTO CARE
STEINBERG AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KATIE HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WERE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SB.
FIFTY GOOD MORNING MIKE MONEY
GOING TO BE HALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
MARYLAND AND BREED IN SUPPORT.
IT'S YOUR TURN MEMBERS MICHAEL
OUT ON BEHALF OF CLUB ONE AT
LARGE PRIVATE EMPLOYER IN
DOWNTOWN FRESNO IN SUPPORT.
MY CLUB INSTANT ON BEHALF UBER
AND SPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP ROUTE
WITH THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT.
SYLVIA SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN STRONG SUPPORT WE
LOOK FOR IF IF THE BILL IS
PASSED AND SIGNED WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC SAFETY ON
THIS.
MEASURE THANKS.
GOOD MORNING BY SHOPPER
REPRESENTING CAL ASIAN CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL --
EIGHTY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
TWO SPEAKERS TWO MINUTES ALL
OTHERS WOULD BE ME TO SET THE
MOOD AT THE MIKE TO THE LEFT MY
LEFT.
OKAY I WAS JUST TOLD THAT EACH
GET WHAT MADE IT SO THAT'S FINE.
I'M FIDGETING TODAY SOME DO THE
BEST I CAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
GORGEOUS.
I THANK THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
CARSON BUT WHAT'S FREDRICKSON
THE RESEARCH MANAGER FOR ALCOHOL
JUSTICE IN SAN RAFAEL CALIFORNIA.
I'M COURSE MY JOB I HAVE
REVIEWED THE PREPONDERANCE OF
THE I WANT TO STRESS THIS THE
PEER REVIEWED PUBLISHED
SCIENTIFIC LITERATURE.
AROUND LAST CALL TIMES --
AS SUCH THERE'S THIRTY YEARS OF
OF OF RESEARCH FROM ACROSS
DEVELOP WORLD NORTH AMERICA THE
U. S. EUROPE'S DESTROY IT CETERA
SHOWING THE LAST CALL TIMES.
ARE EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING
DANGEROUS DRIVING.
AND STRESS AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES THIS VIEW IS SHARED BY
THE CDC THE WHL THE US SURGEON
GENERAL THE NAIONAL ACADEMY OF
SCIENCES AMONG OTHERS --
ENDS FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE
STATEMENT I JUST LIKE TO STRESS --
THE DATA SHOWING THAT --
LAST CALL TIMES TEN TO MAKE --
DANGEROUS DRIVING AND ALCOHOL
RELATED COLLISIONS AND AND
INJURIES GO UP --
DRIVING QUESTIONS INJURIES GO UP
GO UP.
AND THAT --
THE TENS THAT WHEN YOU SEE LATE
LAST CALL TIMES YOU SEE EIGHT
CLUSTERING OF THESE TOWARDS THE
AREAS WITH THE LAST CALL TIMES.
AT POINT IS WORTH TAKING EXTRA
ROOM CONSIDER HOW CALL A CAR
CRASHES DO NOT OBEY LOCAL
CONTROL.
WE KNOW FROM --
VENTURA COUNTY'S OWN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DATA THE DRIVERS THAT
WILL DIRECTLY ARE APPREHENDED
FOR DANGEROUS DRIVING AS MUCH AS
FORTY MILES FROM WHERE THEY LAST
DRANK.
SO SOON AS YOU FIND PEOPLE
TRAVELING FROM CITY TO CITY --
AS OPPOSED TO A WITHIN THE CITY
YOU FIND RIDE SHARING USE GOES
TO NAIL IT PEOPLE DON'T WRITE
USE RIGHT DURING THAT WAY.
SO PEOPLE WILL TRAVEL TO FINALLY
TO BARK PART TIME AND WE KNOW
AGAIN FROM U. S. BASED RESEARCH
THAT THIS THE TO DO THIS AND IN
FACT WE KNOW THIS IS ESSENTIALLY
A FEATURE AND NOT A NOT A FULL
ON THE BILL.
ARE THE NEW CITY CAN POSSIBLE
CONTROL WHEN THEIR NEIGHBORS
DECIDE TO DISREGARD BY PUBLIC
HEALTH BEST PRACTICES AND SAFETY
IN IN SETTING THEIR LAST CALL
POLICIES LATE.
I'M WORDS WHAT'S WORSE IS WE
HAVE SIGNIFICANT BORE --
BARRIERS IN LOCALITIES BEING
ABLE TO RAISE REVENUE TOP.
AND WHEN IT COMES --
TO TO TO TO TO TO CLAIM THE
LOCAL CONTROL IS SOMETHING SORT
OF GREAT GOOD EXCEPT WHEN IT
COMES TO COMPENSATE FOR THE
HARMS ALCOHOL CAUSES AT AN
INCOHERENT POSITION.
SO WE BELIEVE THIS BILL IS SHORT
SIGHTED WOULD BRING MANIFEST
HARM TO ANY CITY OPTING TO ADOPT
LAST CALLS AND ITS NEIGHBORS.
AND WOULD HARM THESE THESE --
WOULD LEAVE THE STATE CITIES NOT
ADOPTING LAST CALLS WITH HARM
WITH NO WAY TO COMPENSATE FOR
THE HARM AND AS SUCH I ASK YOU
TO VOTE NO ONE SB FIFTY EIGHT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT SPEAKER.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SAID
GENESIS HAD AS I AM A MOTHER
DAUGHTER A GRANDDAUGHTER IN A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE FOR CREATE
TELL LOS ANGELES.
TODAY COME REPRESENTING THE
COALITION TO PREVENT ALCOHOL
RELATED HARMS AND ELLIE METRO A
COALITION TO PREVENT SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS A REPRESENTS THE
NEIGHBORHOODS OF BOYLE HEIGHTS
KOREATOWN SKID ROW IN HOLLYWOOD.
NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE THESE ARE
OVERWHELMED BY THE OVER
SATURATION OF ALCOHOL RETAIL
LOCATIONS ARE DESPERATELY
LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
ITS NEGATIVE IMPACTS.
ON PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY AS A
COALITION WE SEEK TO BOLSTER
RESILIENCE AND COMMUNITIES
INCREASING LOCAL OVER SAY WITH
REGARDS TO ALCOHOL IS AN
EFFECTIVE STRATEGY TO BUILD.
HEALTHY PRODUCTIVE IN
COLLABORATIVE COMMUNITIES I WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN KOREATOWN
PLACE KNOWN FOR ITS NIGHTLIFE.
GROWING UP IN KOREATOWN MY
CURFEW WAS AS SOON AS SCHOOL WAS
OUT.
AS AN ADULT I KNOW I NOW
UNDERSTAND WHY LIVING IN AN AREA
WHERE THERE IS AN OVERWHELMING
AMOUNT OF OVER SATURATION
CONCENTRATION OF THE ALCOHOL
OUTLETS DID NOT MAKE IT IDEAL TO
FOSTER.
HEALTHY GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
IN MYSELF FOR ANY OTHER CHILD
TODAY I STAND IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIFTY EIGHT SINCE STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT THERE'S A
CORRELATION BETWEEN INCREASE
ALCOHOL AVAILABILITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY.
AND AN INCREASE ALCOHOL RELATED
HARMS CRIME IN LONG TERM
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS IN
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES AS A
WHOLE.
THE CLAIM THAT NIGHT LIFE IS
CRITICAL TO BE A LITTLE THE
GREAT POTENTIAL AND ABILITIES
THAT EXIST IN OUR COMMUNITIES
APART FROM FROM SUBSTANCE CONF
CONSUMPTION.
MY CONCERN WITH THIS BILL IS
THAT LOW INCOME AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WILL BE IMPACTED THE
MOST FAMILIES WHO ARE IN
CONSTANT SURVIVAL MODE AND HAVE
LIMITED LITERACY OR LUXURY OF
TIME.
BECOME TARGETS FOR THE EXPANSION
OF NIGHT LIFE NIGHTLIFE IS NOT
MEANT OR GEARED AT QUOTE ON
QUOTE RESPONSIBLE DECISIONS AND
IT PERPETUATES JUDGMENT
IMPAIRMENT HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
SEX EXPLOITATION AMONG MANY
OTHER ISSUES.
AS A MOTHER I KNOW THAT THIS IS
NOT THE TYPE OF COMMUNITY I WISH
MY CHILDREN TO BE RAISED IN AS
AN ADVOCATE I KNOW THAT THIS IS
NOT THE COMMUNITIES ARE FAMILIES
HOPE TO RAISE THEIR CHILDREN IN
EITHER.
TODAY I STAND AGAINST IN
OPPOSITION OF KOREAN BAR BILL
NOT JUST FOR MYSELF BUT FOR
THOSE STUDENTS DO HOON WHO DO
NOT HAVE A VOICE DUE TO THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS AGE.
LANGUAGE BARRIER OR ANY OTHER
HINDRANCE I'M HERE FOR MY
COMMUNITY MY COALITION KOLPAN
HAS ALSO TAKEN A STRONG POSITION.
ON SB FIFTY EIGHT THIS DOES NOT
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES AND TODAY
I'M HERE FOR THE VOICES THAT CAP
BE HERE FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT THESE
MEETINGS EXIST.
SO I REALLY ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT TRULY GET AFFECTED BY BILLS
LIKE THESE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
NEXT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS SERRA
BLANCHE I AM A CONSTITUENT FROM
VENICE BEACH CALIFORNIA.
I AM ALSO A CO CHAIR OF THE LOS
ANGELES DRUG AND ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE.
WE HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT SB.
FIFTY EIGHT THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL SAYS THAT IT'S ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL.
BUT THE DECISION.
THAT THE PILOT CITIES LOS
ANGELES WEST HOLLYWOOD LONG
BEACH AMONG THEM.
MAKES ABOUT THIS DIRECTLY TAKES
CONTROL AWAY FROM DOZENS.
OF CITIES THAT ARE ADJACENT TO
THEM.
PASADENA HERMOSA BEACH CARSON
HAS SO MANY OTHER CITIES AROUND
CALIFORNIA.
WELL HAVE TO PICK UP THE PIECES --
FROM DRIVERS WHO BEEN DRINKING
TILL FOUR AM PASSING THROUGH.
THE BE FORCED TO PAY FOR THE
ADDITIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
EMERGENCY SERVICES COSTS THAT
WILL INEVITABLY BE REQUIRED.
WHEN IT COMES TO LOCAL CONTROL
FOR MOST CALIFORNIA CITIES SB
FIFTY EIGHT TAKES IT AWAY?
I'M I WE LIVE AND WORK ON THE
WEST SIDE.
AS PART OF MY WORK ON CALL TO
SPEAK WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS ON
A REGULAR BASIS.
IT IS A VERY DENSELY
CONCENTRATED AREA WHEN IT COMES
TO ALCOHOL BUSINESSES THERE ARE
BARS AND RESTAURANTS AND CLUBS
THAT ARE ABOUT IT UP AGAINST
RESIDENTIAL AREAS IN SOME
INSTANCES TWELVE FEET ACROSS.
FROM ACROSS AN ALLEY FROM
PEOPLE'S BEDROOMS.
THEY DON'T WANT.
LEADER SERVING WHAT'S MORE
DRUNKENNESS THEY DON'T WANT MORE
NOISE THEY DON'T WANT MORE
FIGHTING THEY DON'T WANT MORE
PUBLIC NUISANCE PERIOD THEY
DON'T WANT THIS BILL.
IN CLOSING I WOULD SAY THAT THIS
BILL IS DESCRIBED AS A PILOT
PROGRAM.
I WOULD ARGUE STRONGLY THIS
CONCEPT DOES NOT NEED TO BE
PILOTED.
THIS HAS BEEN TRIED ON IN CITIES
INTERNATIONALLY AND IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND AS MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED.
THE PEER REVIEWED SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE.
INDICATES IRREFUTABLY THAT THERE
ARE INCREASES THAT DRAMATIC
IMPACT THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY SO AS BAD.
OUR MY OFTEN BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU A
QUESTION OF ECONOMICS QUESTION
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
ECONOMIC CAN BE A VERY STRONG
MOTIVATOR.
BUT AS IS EVIDENCED BY THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE FROM THE CITIES
HERE IN SUPPORT.
WE ASKED TODAY THAT YOU CHOOSE
ON THE SIDE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS VERY
DANGEROUS BILL.
YOUR FIRST BIG WHICH SPEAKER TRY
TO HOLD A TWO MINUTE IF YOU
COULD.
GO AHEAD YOU'RE THE CLOSER.
BOB GOOD MORNING TURNED OUT OF
I'M SORRY. TO WORK HERE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAW I'M DOUBLE
MORE PREVENTION COORDINATOR FOR
BEING ABLE HEALTH SERVICES.
INC IN HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA.
A AND A MEMBER OF LA DOPPLER.
BEING A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE IN
HOLLYWOOD HAS A SPECIAL
CHALLENGES THAT YOU KNOW
HOLLYWOOD IS KNOWN FORCE MY LIFE
AND NOT THE WHOLE PLAYS A BIG
PART IN IT [inaudible]
THE I CLOSELY WORK WITH LAPD
HOLLYWOOD DIVISION AND THEY
SAYING A MAJORITY OF THE
RESEARCH HAS GOAL TO DEALING
WITH IN MY LIFE DALY.
YOU KNOW.
IF YOU ASK THEM.
I WOULD SAY 75% OF THEIR
OFFICERS WORK OVERNIGHT.
AND ONLY.
TWENTY FIVE DURING THE WHOLE DAY --
ALCOHOL RELATED CRIME A NUISANCE
ACTIVITY IS ON A RISE IN
HOLLYWOOD AND IS FURTHER
EXACERBATED BY THE HOMELESS
ISSUE.
AND RECENT LEGALIZATION OF
MARIJUANA. TO EXTEND SERVING
HOURS BEYOND JM ONLY STRETCH
PLEASE DEPARTMENTS LIMITED
RESOURCES AND CAUSE UNDUE STRESS
ON POLICE FORCE BARELY KEEPING
UP PACE WITH.
CRIME IN THE AREA.
COMMUTING TRAFFIC CAN ONLY BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THIS
MEASURE.
SPREAD OUT THE AT WHICH AT THE
TIME AT WHICH DO YOU EYES.
ARE MOST PREVALENT. FOR THE
STRETCHING Là FOR SOME
RESOURCES.
HI THE HIGH RIDGE PATROLS
ALREADY.
EXPRESSED DOUBTS ABOUT THIS
ENDEAVOR.
AND I WOULD CONSIDER THEM THE
FOREMOST AUTHORITY ON THIS KIND
OF STUFF --
CONCERNS AS FAR AS TRAFFIC AND
PEDESTRIANS AND HOW IT AFFECTS
THE NEGATIVELY.
HOLLYWOOD HAS MORE TO OFFER.
AND JUST TALK ALL.
AND THESE TRAVEL AGENTS SAYING
THAT ALL THE HALL IS TENDERNESS.
90% OF PEOPLE I SEE WALKING A
HORRIBLE WORK.
OUT WHAT ABOUT ALL THEY WANT TO
SEE THE HOLLYWOOD SIGN.
THEY WANT TO SEE A MOVIE STAR.
WE WANT TO SEE THESE ICONIC.
THINGS THAT ARE IN OUR AREA
CRITICS OBSERVATORY.
SO.
TO THE BASE ARE [inaudible]
QUOTE UNQUOTE --
HOSPITALITY SLASH TOURISM DOWN
TO JUST ALL CALL.
MAGUS IS FOR SHORT.
TERM ANYWAY IF THEY WANNA CALL
[inaudible]
SOME.
YOU KNOW HOLLYWOOD HAS. TEN AND
JUST YOU KNOW.
THE BEST WAYS FOR THE RESIDENTS
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S WHO'S
BASICALLY BEEN IN MY EAR LATELY
IS LIKE YOU KNOW WE HAVE ENOUGH
I'LL CALL WE DON'T NEED.
MORE REASON TO SERVE A LONGER.
NOT SO I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND
CONSIDER THE REAL HUMAN
CONSEQUENCES WHEN VOTED ON THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW
WE WILL TAKE ME TOO SO NAME
ORGANIZATION AND ME.
TOO MORRELL MARSHALL ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN DIEGO POLICE CHIEFS
AND SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
BILL MOTT MEN'S RESIDENT OF THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO --
ONE OF RESIDENTS WAS NEVER --
AT ANY OPPORTUNITY FOR INPUT ON
THIS BILL BEFORE THE CITY
COUNCIL SACRAMENTO SUPPORTED IT --
KERR IF THIS BILL PASSES.
US SOMEONE DRINKING AND WHAT
SACRAMENTO CAN COME ACROSS THE
BRIDGE IN LESS THAN FIVE MINUTES
AND BE IN MID TOWN.
AFTER GETTING LAST CALL AT TWO
AM AND DRINK FOR ANOTHER TWO
HOURS IN MID TOWN.
THIS BILL IF PASSED WILL BE A
DISASTER FOR THE CITY AND
SURROUNDING CITIES AND FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
I TURN SPEAKERS NAME
ORGANIZATION AND ME.
TOO THANK WELL BUT ALL THE
OTHERS GOT TO HAVE THEIR LITTLE
DAD TO I'M SORRY WE HAVE. TO
JUST.
WAIT WITH THE ALCOHOL AND DRUG
ABUSE PREVENTION TEAM SANTA MON
VALLEY AND I HOPE YOU LISTEN
VERY CAREFULLY TO THE WORDS OF
MY COLLEAGUE GENESIS AND TAKE
THAT INTO.
FRED JONES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON ALCOHOL
PROBLEMS IN OPPOSITION WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT THE
GRAPH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JAMIE RICH ON BEHALF OF ADAPT
Là MERENDA WHERE NONE OF THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND CONTRA
COSTA THANK THIS IS A GOOD IDEA.
THANK YOU --
SAY NO OTHERS SPEAKERS IS PUT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
CENTER BARGES FIRST THEY WILL GO
TO CENTER ARCHER LET AFTER THAT.
THANK YOU I WANTED TO RUN.
RE STATE A COUPLE OF KEY
COMPONENTS OF THIS --
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THAT I THINK TEND TO GET
OVERLOOKED --
BECAUSE THIS ISSUE WAS CERTAINLY --
INSPIRES THE PASSIONS ARE ONE
THE REASON WHY I AM SUPPORTING --
THIS -- THIS --
PROPOSED PIECE OF LEGISLATION IS
BECAUSE THE DECISION.
IS -- IT
WILL BE PLACED IN THE HANDS OF
LOCAL AUTHORITIES.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT --
WHEN THIS ISSUE OF IF IT IF IT
GETS APPROVED THROUGH THIS BODY
AND DOWN THE LINE?
THAT ARE FRESNO FOR EXAMPLE I
USE FRESNO BECAUSE THAT'S THE
AREA I REPRESENT THAT'S ONE OF
THE D. PROPOSED PILOT AREAS.
I CONSULTED WITH THE THE MAYOR
OF THE CITY OF FRESNO I
CONSULTED WITH THE POLICE CHIEF
OF THE CITY OF FRESNO.
BOTH OF WHOM OFFERED THEIR
SUPPORT PRINCIPALLY BECAUSE IT
WAS GOING TO GO THROUGH A LOCAL
PROCESS.
AND IT WAS GOING TO LOOK AT THE
LOCAL FACTORS HE WAS GOING TO
LOOK AT THE LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS AND ALL THE
EXTERNALITIES OF VARIABLES THAT
GO INTO.
A LOCAL DECISION MAKING.
AND ALSO TAKE IT IS IT.
THAT I THOUGHT WAS KEY.
SO PUTTING THEM ON THE LIST OF
OF A PROPOSED CITIES IN A PILOT
PROGRAM.
IS ONLY MAKING THEM ELIGIBLE TO
MAKE CONSIDERATIONS ON THEIR OWN.
AND I THAT I THINK IS A VERY
SMART WAY OF MOVING THIS PROJECT
FORWARD.
IS THATTHE CITY PRISON DECIDES
NOT TO DO IT HE DOES NOT HAVE.
TO AND THERE'S ALSO WHETHER --
APPROVALS THAT HE TO BE GOTTEN.
TOM THREE BC AND SO ON SO FORTH
SO FOR THAT REASON --
I'M GOING TO DEFER TO MINE.
ARE THE LOCAL LEADERSHIP AND MY
DISTRICT --
TO GO THROUGH ITS COMMUNITY
PROCESS AND SEE IF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED FEEL THE SAME WAY OF
THOSE WHO WANT TO HAVE MORE
ENTERTAINMENT FOUR OR MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY --
CONSIDERATIONS SO WITH THAT --
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
THERE ARE CHIRLA.
YES THANK YOU CENTER FOR MAKING
THE PRESENTATION IN AN ARC
KNOWLEDGE --
EVERYONE WHO SPOKE TODAY OF I
HAVE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
BACKGROUND SO MY CONCERN.
OF WOULD BE PUBLIC SAFETY NO
DOUBT.
AND SO MY QUESTION IS --
HAVE YOU IN DEPTH --
WORK WITH TALKED WITH SOME OF
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS OF
THE CITY'S NAME --
AND ALSO BEING A FORMER MAYOR OF
A CITY I KNOW THAT THE ISSUE
LIKE THIS COMING FOR CITY
COUNCIL OF ALSO BRINGS IN THE
VOICE TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
AND THAT'S WHY I CAN SEE THAT IF
THE COMMUNITY HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY --
TO HEAR ALL THE FACTS THEN THE
COMMUNITIES THEMSELVES CAN GO
HEAD GO IN THAT DIRECTION.
I'M ALSO IMPRESSED WITH THE FACT
THAT THAT WOULD BE TWENTY TWO
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS AND THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL HAVE THE
TAX FOR INVOLVED WITH ABC.
AND THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT I
A LOOK FOR IT OF COURSE THE
HIGHWAY PATROL.
IS MENTIONED IN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TAX OPERATE IN SOME
OF THE SUCCESS YOU HAD WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
YEAH THANK YOU --
CENTER FOR THE QUESTION AND WE
HAVE A WORKED EXTENSIVELY
PARTICULARLY WITH THE POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND WITH C.
H. P. -- AND
BOTH OF THEM OFFERED AMENDMENTS --
THAT WE ACCEPTED AND THAT'S WHY --
AS YOU NOTED THERE ARE IS A VERY
STRUCTURED PROCESS WITH
MANDATORY PARTICIPATION BY LOCAL
POLICE AND BY CHP --
SO WE'VE --
WE DEFINITELY THERE WAS A
PRIORITY FOR ME TO WORK CLOSELY.
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT --
AND I I THINK IT MADE THE BILL --
BETTER -- IN
TERMS OF PUTTING THOSE PUBLIC
SAFETY CARD COUNSEL FORMULATE A
PUBLIC SAFETY PLAN AND THE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN --
AND ABC HAS TO VERIFY THAT THEY
ACTUALLY DID THAT ON AND THEN --
AS I NOTED BEFORE FOR EACH AND
EVERY -- AND
THIS IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE'VE HAVING SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION YOU WOULD THINK THAT
THE SERVICES BILL GET SIGNED.
ALL THE SUDDEN YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE ALL THESE VENUES OPENING AND
IT IT IN ADDITION TO THE LOCAL
PROCESS TO HOUSE TAKE PLACE --
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER ON EVERY
SINGLE MONTH TO PASS THE
ORDINANCE NOTHING HAPPENS UNTIL
OF BAR NIGHTCLUB MAKES AN
APPLICATION TO ABC --
AS IS THE NORMAL PRACTICE AND AS
A FORMER LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
WELL YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THIS.
THEN THEY CUT --
ABC ALWAYS SIX IMPORT FROM THE
LOCAL POLICE CAPTAIN A POLICE
CHIEF WHO MAKES A RECOMMENDATION
AND DOESN'T INVESTIGATION.
AND SO LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
INVOLVED AT EVERY SINGLE STEP OF
THIS PROCESS.
BY WHICH MAKES ME CONFIDENT THAT
THIS IS GOING TO BE DONE IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BRADFORD.
THANK YOU I'M SURE I'M SERIOUS.
ABSENT ALCOHOL COULD A
ESTABLISHMENT MAKE AN
APPLICATION TO STAY OPEN PASSED
TO HIM AND NOT SERVE ALCOHOL THE
THEY CAN --
THERE AND THERE ARE --
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I ASSUME IN
LA NOW THERE ARE --
PER.
THE REALITY IS THAT ECONOMICS TO
COME INTO PLAY --
AND THESE ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
SMALL BUSINESSES --
THAT -- YOU
KNOW THEY THEY NEED TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE THEIR PAYROLL AND COVER
THEIR EXPENSES --
AND SO THAT YOU KNOW.
ALCOHOL DOES --
PLAY INTO THAT --
BUT YES THEY KIND IT'S NOT VERY
COMMON --
BUT THIS WILL --
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF VENUES
THAT ARE ABLE. TO DO THAT THE
FOOD SERVICE COULD BE PART OF
THAT AS WELL.
TWO IF YOU CAN TO OUR YES --
AND RIGHT YES YOU CAN CONTINUE
TO SERVE --
TO AND AND THAT'S NOT AFFECTED
AT ALL.
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD BOTH POINT
CONDOM COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I LIKE THAT ASPECT OF
LETTING AND CITIES DECIDE IF IN
FACT THIS IS NOT A BLANKET.
YOU KNOW A PERMIT TO DO IT
AUTOMATICALLY SHOULD FOR
CONSIDERATION BUT I'VE HEARD
FROM A LOT OF FOLKS YOU.
STAY OUT LATE I USED TO BE IN A
CLUB PROMOTION BUSINESS A LOT OF
FOLKS WOULD LIKE THE STOPS MEANT
TO STAY OPEN A LITTLE LATER FOR
THOSE WHO HE HAD A DRINK UP TO
TWO O'CLOCK.
AND ALLOW THEM TO SOBER UP A
LITTLE BIT FIRST IS HITTING THE
STREET.
AT A HARD STOP AT TWO O'CLOCK SO
IT'S FOR PROS AND CONS AND THOSE
EXTENDED HOURS AS WELL SO
[inaudible]
ANYTHING ELSE.
I JUST HAVE TO TELL YOU I SO
ADMIRE YOU AS A LEGISLATOR.
EVERY TIME YOU.
I'VE BEEN A NO ON THE BILL ON
THE BEAT I KNOW IN THE BILL
AGAIN TODAY BUT EVERY TIME YOU
BROUGHT THIS BILL BACK IT'S
GOTTEN BETTER AND BETTER MAYBE
WE SHOULD --
HAVE A VETO IT AGAIN THEY WILL
BE EVEN BETTER NEXT YEAR.
HELLO A KID ON THAT BUT I'VE I
PRE I APPRECIATE ALL THE
SAFEGUARDS I APPRECIATE ALL THE
DILIGENT WORK AND EVEN VERY
THOROUGH FOR ME JUST ONE LIFE IS
TOO MANY I CAN'T GET THERE EVEN
THOUGH I'M A LOCAL CONTROL GUY.
YOU CERTAINLY DONE THAT PILOT I
MEAN I COULDN'T ASK YOU TO DO
ANYMORE THAN YOU'VE DONE I JUST
PHILOSOPHICALLY I I CAN GET
THERE BUT REALLY --
PRECIADO YOUR EFFORTS AND WITH
THAT YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND CLOSE.
I THANK YOU A HI MISTER SHERMAN
FOR A FOR THIS REMARKS I
COMPLETELY RISK FAMILY HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED --
BY -- BY
DRUNK DRIVING AND AS SOMEONE WHO
HAVE YOU KNOW THE THE WHEN I WAS
ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ONE
OF THE NEIGHBORHOODS I
REPRESENTATIVE WAS A VERY
INTENSIVE.
NIGHT LIFE AREA WE ALWAYS HAVE
TO WORK VERY HARD TO BALANCE ALL
THE VARIOUS NEWS I I RESPECT
THAT.
I JUST A FEW THINGS I WANT TO
MENTION --
ONE IS IN TERMS OF AND NOT THE
ISSUE OF NEIGHBORING TOWNS
NEIGHBORING CITIES AND AN
ABSOLUTELY IF ONE CITY DECIDE TO
DO SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW THAT THEIR NEIGHBORING
CITIES AS WELL WE ACTUALLY PUT A
PROVISION IN WHICH I NEGLECTED
THAT WHEN A CITIES CONSIDERING
DOING THIS THEY HAVE TO SEND
NOTIFICATION TO ALL OF THEIR
NEIGHBORING CITIES INVITING
FEEDBACK FROM THOSE CITIES.
AND WALL YES THIS CREATES
DIFFERENT CLOSING TIMES IN
DIFFERENT CITIES AND THERE WAS A
COMMENT MADE ON THAT --
WE HAVE THAT NOW BECAUSE NOT
EVERYSTOP NOT EVERY CITY GOES
TO TO I AM NOT SOME CITIES
REQUIRE EARLIER CLOSER. FOR YOU
AND SO YOU ALREADY TODAY HAVE
AREAS ARE CLOSE AT MIDNIGHT OR
ONE OR TWO SO IF IF STAGGER
CLOSING TIMES AN ISSUE.
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT EXISTS
RIGHT NOW TERMS OF SOME COMMENTS
OR SATURATION IN SOME
NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH I AGREE
THERE ARE NEIGHBORHOODS IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND LA AND ELSEWHERE
WITH OVERSATURATION OF ALCOHOL
ESTABLISHMENTS.
ON MY IN MY EXPERIENCE DOT OVER
SATURATION IS IS FREQUENTLY
ABOUT LIQUOR STORES WE HAVE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE THEY'RE WAY TOO MANY
LIQUOR STORES --
AND NOT CAUSES SO MANY OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE SEE AROUND --
ALCOHOL AND AND CHRONIC
ALCOHOLISM --
AND SO CITIES.
TODAY AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THEIR OWN ABILITY TO SAY WE
DON'T WANT MORE ESTABLISHMENTS
OR WE WANT FEWER ESTABLISHMENT
SO WE'RE GOING.
TO NOT SUPPORT NEW LIQUOR
LICENSES THEY CAN DO THAT NOW
THAT IS A LOCAL ISSUE AND THIS
WAS SIMPLY NOT CHANGE THAT --
SO COLLEAGUES NIGHT LIFE IS
IMPORTANT --
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
OR CALL THE ROLL SHIN --
SORRY [inaudible]
THEIR MOTION.
OKAY SO THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND SENT TO A PROBES.
FILE ITEM FIVE SB FIFTY EIGHT
MOTIONS YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DODD.
WILK NO BOOK NOW ALLEN.
ARCHULETA YES ARCHULETA HI.
REGIS. FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
HILL.
HILL I WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE. SIXTY TWO
WILL.
OKAY CENTER WHERE THE CURRENT
VOTERS SAY YES SIX NO TWO WILL
HOLD THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO
ADD ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES
.
FILE ITEM.
FOR SENATOR WILL GIVE ITEM FOR
SB [inaudible]
FIVE THREE PLEASE PROCEED.
BY THAT IS THAT IS.
IS SHE HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THIS WEEK TO SIGN THE SUNLIGHT
FOUNDATION WHICH IS A
NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO GOVERNMENT
TRANSPARENCY CALLS TO SUNSHINE
WEEK.
SO I THINK IT'S VERY FITTING
THAT TODAY THAT WE PRESENT THIS
MEASURE SB FIFTY THREE WHICH
GUARANTEES CALIFORNIANS HAS
ACCESS TO MEETINGS OF ALL
OFFICIALS STATE BODIES.
SB FIFTY THREE FIXES A LOOPHOLE.
IN THE BAGLEY KEENE OPEN
MEETINGS ACT TO ENSURE COMPLETE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR STATE GOVERNMENT.
EXISTING LAW ALLOWS STATE
AGENCIES BOARDS ANOTHER
GOVERNMENTAL BODIES TO FORMAT
VICE RESET COMMITTEES THAT DO
NOT HAVE TO COMPLY WITH OPENING
OPEN MEETING REQUIREMENTS.
AS LONG AS THEY ONLY HAVE TWO
MEMBERS.
THESE COMMITTEES ARE CAPABLE OF
WIELDING SIGNIFICANT POWER AND
INFLUENCE BUT ARE ABLE TO CLOSER
MEETINGS OFF TO THE PUBLIC
BECAUSE OF A TECHNICALITY IN
CURRENT LAW.
A NUMBER STATE AGENCIES AND
BOARDS HAVE EXPLOITED CURRENT
LAW TO KEEP THEIR OPERATIONS
HIDDEN FROM THE PUBLIC EYE.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO REASON
THAT THESE COMMITTEES TO BE
MEETINGS SUPPORT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO MEMBERS RATHER THAN.
THREE SB FIFTY THREE WILL CLOSE
THAT LOOPHOLE IN GUARANTEE THAT
ALL STATE GOVERNMENT BODIES
OPERATE WITH COMPLETE
TRANSPARENCY --
THE SAME MEASURE I INTRODUCED IN
THE PAST IT RECEIVED EIGHTY AYE
VOTES IN THE ASSEMBLY. FORTY AYE
VOTES IN THE SENATE AND WAS
VETOED -- BY
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION.
SAW BRING IT BACK THIS YEAR --
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ALL HAD THAT
I'VE READ A GOVERNOR NUISANCE
BOOK CITIZENS BILL WHICH TALKS
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY IN GOVERNMENT
AND ALL THE GREAT THINGS HE DID
WHEN HE WAS MAYOR SAN FRANCISCO.
SO I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL
ACT IN THE INTEREST OF THE
PUBLIC AND THAT WE WILL BE --
SUCCESSFUL THIS YEAR IN SECURING
THE GOVERNOR SIGNATURE ON SB.
FIFTY THREE WITH ME TODAY I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE IS FRANCIE
KOHLER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A LICENSE
INVESTIGATORS TO TESTIFY.
WELCOME --
CHAIRMAN DIED IN SENATORS.
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY KELLY SUPPORTS I'M THE
PAST PRESIDENT BY THE WAY AND
CURRENT --
GOVERNMENT FAIRS CHAIR OF THE
ASSOCIATION AND KELLY SUPPORTS
REVISIONS AS OF SB FIFTY THREE
THAT ENHANCE TRANSPARENCY.
MEETINGS HELPING ENSURE THE
PUBLIC.
ARE PROVIDED --
WITH A CRITICAL OPPORTUNITY TO
WILL TO BECOME AWARE OF ISSUES
THE PROCEEDINGS THE DEBORAH
DELIBERATIONS AND THE DECISIONS.
AND THERE WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE MANY IN THOSE MEETINGS
WITH OPEN MEETINGS --
WHEN THEY HAVE THREE OR MORE
INDIVIDUALS AS THE ONES THAT
HAVE THREE OR MORE INDIVIDUALS
AND FOR THESE REASONS CALLIE
SUPPORTS SB FIFTY THREE THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THIS TESTIMONY?
DO WE HAVE ANY --
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OF MEMBERS
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT
SKEWS ME.
YES I WOULD BE PROP CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION --
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
OFTEN ADVISORY COMMITTEES ARE
WHERE THE BASELINE FOR PUBLIC
POLICY IS SET.
AND WHEN THE PUBLIC IS DEPRIVED
OF BEING ABLE TO TAKE PART IN
THOSE MEETINGS AND SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON THEY DON'T GET THE SEAT
AT THE TABLE THAT THEY DESERVES
WE SUPPORT SB.
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER.
IN SUPPORT ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LIKE CLOTHES YEAH
ABSOLUTELY --
I CAN'T RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE I THINK THERE WAS SOME
MISCONCEPTION IN TERMS OF WHAT
THIS --
COVERS IT ONLY COVERS --
COVERS COMMITTEES AND THAT WAS A
DETAILED ANY BE FOURTEEN NINETY
FOUR BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE SO ALL WE'RE DOING IS
TAKING A PROVISION THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN THE BROWN AXIS
NINETEEN NINETY THREE APPLYING
IT TO THE BAGLEY KEENE ACT.
SO OFTEN WE TELL LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DO AS WE SAY NOT AS
WE DO WE NOW WE HAVE A CHANCE AT
THE SAME TRANSPARENCY THEY DO
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY THAT COALITION WITH.
WE HAVE TO MOTIONS TO MOVE THE
BILL BUT WE'LL START WITH THAT
SENATOR --
NIELSEN --
GO AHEAD CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
FILE ITEM FOR SB FIFTY THREE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DODD.
I THOUGHT I WILK I WILL AYE
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D FORGES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I'D CHANGE.
GALGIANI G. ANI AYE GLAZER.
HILL [inaudible]
WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NIELSEN I NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
RUBIO HI RUBIO I WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
IT'S EIGHT TWO ZERO WILL HOLD A
OPEN. EIGHT ZERO ON CENTER WORKS.
TO BILL WILL MOVE ON I AM.
ONE I THINK WE'RE GOING TO GO.
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
OKAY.
SENATOR DODD LIKE TO TAKE UP
ITEM ONE FIRST SB TWENTY
RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS AND SEND
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
A MEMBERS AYE PRESENTING SB
TWENTY TODAY IT WOULD ALLOW NAPA
COUNTY TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES. TO BY THE SEVEN EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY ACRE SKYLINE
WILDERNESS PARK INSURING THE
PRIME LAND WITH POPULAR HIKING
TRAILS AND VIEWS OF THE BAY AND
IT BAY AREA REMAINS A PUBLIC
SPACE FOREVER.
THE SKYLIGHT WILDERNESS PARK IN
NAPA COUNTY IS A VALUABLE PUBLIC
AMENITY NOT ONLY FOR RECREATION
BUT IT'S PRESERVE FOR A
WATERSHED.
IN A RICH WILDLIFE HABITAT JUST
QUICK WHEN I WAS ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS --
WE GOT --
AUTHORIZATION TO BUY THIS TURN
WE COULD NEVER PULL THE TRIGGER
AS A RESULT THAT --
AUTHORIZATION EXPIRED AND I'M
LOOKING TO EXTEND THAT
AUTHORIZATION TODAY --
SO WITH THAT.
WE HAVE A CAPTION I CAROLING
WITH THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AS WELL AS THE NAPA
COUNTY REGIONAL AN OPEN SPACE.
DISTRICT THEY HOLD AT LEAST NOW
THEY'VE BEEN OPERATING IT.
FOR AT DECADES AND THEIR LEASES
NOT EXPIRE FOR ANOTHER ELEVEN
YEARS THE HOPING THAT --
WITH THE ECONOMIC.
ACTIVITY THAT'S BEEN GOING ON
PLUS THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
POTENTIALLY PART AS SALES TAX
MEASURE ON THEIR LOCAL BALLOT IN.
TWENTY TWENTY THERE THE THING
THAT THAT SOURCE OF REVENUE
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO MAKE THE
PURCHASE OF THE PROPERTY
SOMETIME IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS
ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT --
MADELINE OLIVER WITH THE NAPA
COUNTY BICYCLE COALITION AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
TWENTY BECAUSE SO MUCH.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE MOVING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
SEEING NINE CENTER DOT YOU MAY.
I GUESS WE NEED A MOTION TO I
HAVE A MOTION.
MOTION BY IS A CENTER BRADFORD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT
FILE ITEM ONE SB TWENTY MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DOT.
BY GOD I WILL HI WILK AYE ALLEN
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HI GORGEOUS.
GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI CHIANG.
CHANGE HI GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WEST SO [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE. TEN TWO ZERO HOLD
WITH.
ITSELF OKAY ZERO IT OUT BUT WE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON
CONGRATULATIONS I CAN.
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM TO SB TWENTY
ONE AGAIN SENATOR DODD IN THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS TO
PROBATION TO APPROPRIATIONS.
OKAY --
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SB
TWENTY ONE SIMPLY LOWERS THE
REQUIRED MINIMUM BRING
PRODUCTION OF A BREW PUB LICENSE --
AT KNOWN ALSO KNOWN AS THE TYPE
SEVENTY FIVE LICENSE FROM TWO
HUNDRED BARRELS OF BEER. TO ONE
HUNDRED BARRELS.
AS YOU WRITE ME MEMBERS YOU
MIGHT REMEMBER LAST YEAR THAT
FABULOUS BILL --
US BE TWELVE EIGHTY THREE FOR
MADE SEVERAL CHANGES --
TO THE BREW PUB RESTAURANT
LICENSE GRANNY ADDITIONAL
PRIVILEGES --
TO THE LICENSEE AS WELL AS
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS THE DEPARTMENT OF ABC ALL
THOSE ARE FULLY INTACT.
THIS PARTICULAR PROVISION OF THE
BILL THAT WE SEEK TO REVERT BACK
TO WAS BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION
WAY AFTER THE FACT.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE WAS NO
ADVOCATES THE CAME ON BEHALF OF
THE MANY OF THESE TYPES SEVENTY
FIVE LICENSES.
IN CONTINUING --
AND NOT CHANGES THIS BILL COULD
RESULT IN MANY RESTAURANTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I EITHER BECOMING TOTALLY A
PROFITABLE AND US THE OLD REALLY
GOING OUT OF BUSINESS SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
HE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COME UP HERE FEEL LIKE
WHATEVER YOUR PREFERENCES.
HEY FRED JONES I'M I WAS TAPPED
BY OUT CALLED JUSTICE TO GIVE
THEIR PROXY BUT I ALSO REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
ALCOHOL PROBLEMS.
THE CONCERN WE HAVE IS THERE'S
BEEN A HUGE SPIKE IN THE NUMBER
OF TYPE.
SEVENTY FIVE LICENSES IN THE
STATE WE THINK IT'S TO GO AROUND
THE MORE DIFFICULT TYPE FORTY
SEVEN LICENSES AND FRANKLY WE
THINK SOME OF THESE PER PROBE
SUGGESTED --
TO GET --
THEIR LICENSE --
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO THROUGH THE
MORE RIGOROUS AND MORE DIFFICULT
TO FIND A NUMBER OF TYPE FORTY
SEVEN SO.
THAT'S WHAT WE THINK RESULTED --
IN THERE FOR WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THIS EXTENDED FOR ANOTHER
COUPLE YEARS LET'S SEE WHAT THE
REAL IMPACT IS BUT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT TYPE.
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY PULL BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTSCONCERNS
MISTER BRADFORD THANK YOU MISSED
YEAR ON YES I WAS AUTHORED
TWELVE EIGHTY THREE LARGER AND I
APPRECIATE TO SUPPORT THAT THIS
COMMITTEE AND CHAIRMAN ARE
PROVIDED AS WE MOVE.
FOR AND AS WE OFTEN SAY THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
LEGISLATION THAT HAS GOOD
INTENTIONS AND IT WAS BY NO
MEANS --
WHEN WE WERE RUNNING THIS BILL
TO PUT THE STRESS AND STRAIN ON
THOSE BREW PUBS WE'VE BEEN
NOTIFIED OF SOME THOSE
CHALLENGES SO REDUCE IT FROM TWO
HUNDRED BARRELS DOWN TO A
HUNDRED I THINK IS COMMON SENSE
AND?
HOPEFULLY OF THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN THRIVE IN HERE TO
NOT JUST MAKE A PROFIT BUT
PROVIDE A QUALITY PRODUCT AS
WELL SO I SUPPORT THE MEASURE --
BARGES.
JUST JUST ECHO THAT I THINK --
AND IT'S STILL WITHIN THE
REASONABLE CATEGORY IT ALSO
MAKES AVAILABLE --
FOR FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PRODUCTS THAT MAY NOT BE IS COST
EFFECTIVE EL ESPECIALLY NEXT
BERMAN TATIAN STAGE SO I WOULD
SUPPORT THIS AS WELL.
RIGHT LOOKING FOR MOTION.
MOTION BY MISTER BRADFORD AGAIN
IT IS TO PASS.
GO FOR OKAY NATURE CLOSE OKAY
GOOD.
CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM TO SB
TWENTY ONE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE DOT.
HI DODD I WILL BUY WILK AYE
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D BARGES.
BARGES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHANGE.
CHANGE HIGH GALGIANI GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WESTELL [inaudible]
JONES.
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER HI. NINE ZERO IT OUT JUST.
CAN NINE ZERO SO THE THE BILLS
OUT WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND OUR FINAL
BILL OF THE DAY.
IS FILE ITEM SEVEN AS HE WON
NEED MY READERS MISTER POTTER
SMALL AT ONE NINETY PLEASE BEAR
IN MEMBERS SB.
ONE NINETY REX THE OFFICE OF
STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO ENHANCE
AWARENESS OF IN COMPLIANCE WITH
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENTS TO
BETTER PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES.
FOR FUTURE WILDFIRES JUST THIS
PAST WEEK CAL FIRE RELEASED A
REPORT THAT STRESS THE NEED FOR
THE STATE TO TAKE COMPREHENSIVE
ACTIONS IN ADDRESSING VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND A HARDENING
HOMES SB ONE NINETY DIRECTS THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO DEVELOP A
MODEL DEFENSIBLE SPACE ORDINANCE
FOR CONSIDERATION BY
JURISDICTIONS WHICH MAY NOT HAVE
ONE IN PLACE.
REQUIRES THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
DEVELOP A DEFENSIBLE SPACE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT FOR REFERENCE
IN OUR GREEN BUILDING STANDARDS
AND FOR DEBTS TO BE SHOULD TO
NEW HOME BUYERS.
REQUIRES STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
PRODUCE AND MAKE AVAILABLE ON
THE INTERNET. EIGHT WE E
STANDARDS COMPLIANCE MANUAL TO
HELP TRAIN CONTRACTORS BUILDING
OFFICIALS --
IT FIRE SERVICE IN THE PUBLIC --
LASTLY IT REQUIRES THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL TO DEVELOP AND
MAINTAIN.
IT MIGHT PUT OUT TO THAT RIGHT
LOUIS YES ALL RIGHT THANK YOU --
COMPLAINT PRODUCT MANUAL
TRACTORS BUILDING OFFICIALS FIRE
SERVICE IN THE GENERAL PUBLIC
TOGETHER THESE RESOURCES WILL
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES TO BE MORE.
RESILIENT FUTURE WILDFIRES WITH
ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE IS BOB ROEMER SENIOR
ENGINEER DID TECHNICAL DIRECTOR
FROM C. B. I A THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATOS ON BOB ROEMER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION --
AND IS THE AUTHORS INDICATED --
THIS BILL REQUIRES A FIRE
MARSHAL TO DO FOUGHT FOR
SPECIFIC TAX --
WITH RELATION TO OUR WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE FIRE SAFETY
RATINGS --
THEY'LL BE PRODUCING --
I COMPLIANCE --
MANUAL ON BEEN PUT THAT ON THE
INTERNET AND IT'S IMPORTANT ARE
BUILDING OFFICIALS FIRE SERVICE
AND OUR CONTRACTORS UNDERSTAND --
THE CLARITY OF HELPLINE THESE
REGULATIONS IN ADDITION WILL BE
UPDATING --
THE COMPLIANT PRODUCT HANDBOOK
OF UPDATING AND PLACE IT ON THE
INTERNET --
FOR DEFENSIBLE SPACE SAW WE'VE
HAD VERY STRICT STATUE RULES IN
PLACE FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS --
BUT THE FACT REMAINS THAT WHILE
MANY JURISDICTIONS OF
IMPLEMENTED THIS.
MOST MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS ARE RARELY
WHERE THE DODD THESE PROVISIONS
EVEN EXISTENCE SO --
THIS HAS THE FIRE MARSHAL WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN DEVELOPING
A MODEL DEFENSIBLE SPACE
ORDINANCES NOT MANDATORY THAT
JURISDICTION'S TAKE IT BUT FOR
THOSE TAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
SOMETHING THIS PROVIDES THEM
SOMETHING ON A SILVER PLATTER.
THEY'RE ABLE TO TAKE IT AND
INSERT COMPONENTS AND WITHDRAW
COMPONENTS DEPENDING ON THEIR
OWN SPECIAL NEEDS --
AND LASTLY --
DIRECTS THE FIRE MARSHAL TO WORK
WITH THE BUILDING STANDARDS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS --
TO BASICALLY --
UPDATE THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT BOARD OF
FORESTRY PUT THIS TOGETHER --
TWENTY YEARS AGO IT'S AND IT'S A
GREAT DOCUMENT IN SERIOUS NEED
OF UPDATING ALL AND PLACING ON
THE INTERNET AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE FIRE MARSHAL BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION.
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND OF
COURSE ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS IN
PRODUCING AND WE SECURE AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT HE WAS SHERMAN KEYSTONE
HERE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION THINKS IS
A PRUDENT MEASURE AND WE'RE
HAPPY.
TO YOUR SUPPORT ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING YELLING COVERED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA --
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SIR IN TAYLOR ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT LARGE PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURERS HEARING
CALIFORNIAN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAD GOOD CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE REGARDING AN
AMENDMENT TO ADD INSURERS AND
INSURANCE RESEARCH ORGANIZATIONS.
TO THE LIST OF CONSULTING
STAKEHOLDERS WITH THAT AMENDMENT
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TO INCREASE AWARENESS IN
COMPLIANCE.
WITH CALIFORNIA'S DEFENSIBLE
SPACE REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU.
FIRST TIME AT THE MIKE YOU LOOK
GOOD.
ANYBODY --
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SINGAPORE BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
SENATE ARCHULETA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR PRESENTING
THIS TO A SET FIRE SAFETY IS ON
ALL OUR MINDS.
CAN YOU GIVE US SOME IDEA OF THE
STRUCTURE IN THE PERIMETER FOR
STAGE IN THE SECOND STAGE IN AND
HOW IT WOULD PREVENT THE
SPREADING OF BOTH SECTIONAL.
STUDIES HAVE DE.
YOUR EIGHT TIMES AS LIKELY TO
MAKE IT THROUGH A WILDFIRE
WITHOUT YOUR HOME BURNING DOWN.
AND SO THAT THAT STAT IO IN
ITSELF.
IS A DEMONSTRABLE PROOF THAT --
WE NEED TO BE DOING MORE WHAT I
WAS COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN NAPA WE
CAME.
FOR TWO YEAH AT THE TIME THIS
WAS THE WHAT WAS BROUGHT FORWARD
ADD WE TRIED TO DO IT AS A BOARD
WE DID WE DID PASS SAID HE HAD --
YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE THE AMOUNT
OF OPPOSITION AND THEY JUST.
CAME OUT OF THE WOODWORK FOR
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS.
AND I WOULD SUGGEST TO YOU TODAY
THAT ALL THOSE PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS HAD WISHED --
THAT THEY'D COOPERATED A LITTLE
BIT MORE FREELY WITH THE BOARD
ON TRYING TO GET SOMETHING --
YOU KNOW DONE THERE CERTAINLY.
AFTER --
YOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
HOMES IN THAT NEIGHBORHOOD
BURNED DOWN --
IN OCTOBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S A GO OUT SENATOR --
THE THE THE GREATER --
THE ODDS ARE THAT YOUR YOUR HOME
WILL BE PROTECTED.
SPACE AREA ALSO SERVICES MORE
SAFER AREA FOR THE FIRE SERVICE
TO STAGE --
AS AN ATTACK ON THE FAR THAT'S
APPROACHING AND SO IT IS SORT OF
A TWO FOR BOTH OF THE PROPERTY
AND FOR THE FIRE SERVICE.
AND THAT'S WHY I AM AND JUST
SUPPORT TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS HOW IMPORTANT IS
THIS TIME AROUND HELLO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AS I HAD
MENTIONED IN ONE OF OUR OTHER
MEETINGS --
WITH THE FIRE MARSHALL'S THAT
WE'VE GOT TO DISSEMINATE THE
INFORMATION WE'VE GOT TO GET --
THE GENERAL PUBLIC INVOLVED IN
THIS FIRE SAFETY BLANK BEGINS
WITH ALL OF US.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS TO
ASSUME YOU HAVE MY SUPPORT.
YES SENATOR ALAN BY JUST WANTED
TO CENTER I'VE SPENT A LOT OF
TIMES MORNING WITH HUGE AREAS
HEARINGS AND I JUST WANNA SEE
HOW NICE IT IS TO SEE YOU
FINALLY COME FOR THE MEETING FOR
BILL THAT ENJOYS CONSENSUS
SUPPORT.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT.
I DO RECALL I GOT THE VOTES TO
GET OUT OF THAT COMMITTEE JUST.
WE OFFER THE PUBLIC IT'S STILL
HERE.
IT WAS SIR COULD YOU COPY YES
BUT YES IN ITSELF I'M LOOKING
FOR TO SUPPORT INITIATIVES
YESTERDAY.
PRICE CENTER.
I'M LOOKING FOR MOTION CASE OF
THE MOTION IS DEAD TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
THAT CENTER WE LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR FILE ITEM SEVEN SB ONE
NINETY MOTION IS DO PASSED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES IN WATER DOT.
HI DODD I WILL HI WILK AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HIGH
FORGES.
GORGEOUS AYE BRADFORD.
HI CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER.
HILL.
HILL AYE WESSEL.
WAS SO I'D JONES.
NIELSEN HI.
NIELSEN AYE PORTANTINO.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER I THIRTEEN STILL FOLDER
TEASER UPSET MEMBERS THAT'S OUT
WILL HOLD OPEN FOR THE OUT TO BE
ABSENT MEMBERS --
WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH.
WITH THE COMMITTEE RULES BECAUSE
THE BILLS YES.
WE'RE GONNA DO THAT BUT WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO HOLD AN OPEN IN
THE END BECAUSE CENTER GLAZER IS
ON ITS WAY.
GO AHEAD THE COMMITTEE RULES.
SO THE COMMITTEE RULES WILL GO
UP FIRST.
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN HI CHANGE [inaudible]
CHIANG I GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER JONES
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO II IS TO MEMBERS WILL
STILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR THEM.
OKAY -- ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB.
TWENTY MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
BEAU IS TEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN I ALLEN AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL AYE WESSEL.
WAS SO I JONES [inaudible]
PORTANTINO. FOURTEEN ZERO STILL
HOLD IT OPEN KING ZERO THAT
STILL WILL BE HELD OPEN SB.
TWENTY ONE SB TWENTY ONE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IT IS NINE ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN.
ALLEN I GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE HILL.
HILL AYE WESSEL.
WITH SO I JONES [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO I FOURTEEN ZERO STILL HOLD
IT OPEN FOR DINO.
WILL HOLD THAT OPEN --
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB FORTY SIX
QUESTION IS DO YOU PASSED TO
RULES COMMITTEE VO IS SEVENTY
ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
I'M SORRY DODD.
DODD AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE FORGES [inaudible]
I'M NOT.
SB FORTY SIX JACKSON.
WE'LL COME BACK TO YOU
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE WEST SO.
BYE SO I'D JONES [inaudible]
PORTANTINO HIGH [inaudible]
PORTANTINO I CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ABSENT MEMBERS BARGES.
GORGEOUS I BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
JONES. TWO THREE FIVE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT NINE SO IT'S THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILLS OUT.
LEAVE IT OPEN. FOR MATTER.
BROWSERS GONNA JONES.
JONES MR OKAY GOING HOTEL SB
FIFTY THREE ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE VO IS
SEVENTY ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN.
AT FILE ITEM FOR SB FIFTY THREE
WILK MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE VO IS
SEVEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN.
GORGEOUS.
GORGEOUS I CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER.
USER I..
HILL.
HILL AYE WEST SO.
BY SO I JONES [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO I FOURTEEN ZERO EIGHT
FOURTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
OF THE WORLD IN THE ROLE BEEN
FOR JOHN JONES --
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB FIFTY EIGHT
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS VOTE IS.
SIX TWO TWO ABSENT MEMBERS DODD
AYE DODD AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I CHIANG.
CHIANG NO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE.
WEST SO.
WHY SO I JONES [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
TINO AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
WHAT'S SO.
WES ID NUMBER.
I'D RATHER STAY UP.
OKAY [inaudible]
ONE TWO THREE HI. EIGHT NINE TEN
FOR TWENTY FOUR GET A HOLD ROLE
OPEN -- WILL
MOVE WANTED OUT TO SB ONE SIXTY
NINE JACKSON.
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
BEAU IS.
TEN TO ONE ABSENT MEMBERS DODD.
HI DODD AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE JONES [inaudible]
RUBIO. THIRTEEN TO ONE ONE OKAY --
SB ONE NINETY ALL THAT OPENS.
SB ONE NINETY MOTION IS DO
PASSED IN NATURAL RESOURCES IN
WATER.
BEAU IS THIRTEEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS GLAZER.
GLAZER II JONES [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
PORTANTINO I SIXTEEN A ON A ON
THIS. FIFTEEN TWO ZERO FIFTEEN
TO ZERO OUT LANDFILLS OUT.
YOU WERE THE ONE SIXTY YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
CENTER.
OPEN UP EVERY SINGLE ONE THAT
WOULD INCLUDE AN EXCELLENT TRIED
TO WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH THE
BILL'S ONE MORE TIME IN A MORE
CLOSE IT OUT.
SO ITEM NUMBER.
ONE I DON'T HAVE A FOR ONE FIFTY
NINE I WISH I MEAN IF I'M IF I'M
IN A RE OPEN A FILE ITEM SIX SB
ONE SIXTY NINE REAL TO NOT.
WHICH SHE DID [inaudible]
HIS.
WHICH IS START FROM THE TOP.
WE'RE GONNA GO WITH BILL NUMBER
ONE WE'RE GOING TO WORK THROUGH
THE ROLE.
STARTING WITH SB.
TWENTY ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE
ROLES THERE YOU GO THANK YOU.
ABSENT MEMBERS GLAZER GLAZER I
AND JONES.
SO THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO OUT.
THE FIFTEEN ZERO THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TWENTY ONE
SKEWS ME I WAS ROLE THAT WAS
RULES YOU'RE RIGHT SB.
TWENTY ITEM NUMBER ONE MOTIONS
YOU PASTOR PREPARATIONS.
CURRENT BROKE FOURTEEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
JONES.
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO I
FIFTEEN ZERO THAT'S OUT. FIFTEEN
ZERO THAT BILLS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
TWENTY ONE MOTIONS YOU PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS.
BEAU IS FOURTEEN ZERO ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
JONES.
PORTANTINO FIVE PORTANTINO I'D
FIFTEEN ZERO THAT'S OUT OF BILLS
OUT.
I'M THREE SB.
FORTY SIX I AM WINNER.
FIVE MICHELLE AND I'M GONNA RUN
OUT.
YES OKAY THANK YOU.
FOR FILE ITEM THREE SB FORTY SIX
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO RULES
COMMITTEE BEAU IS THIRTEEN ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS BRADFORD
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
CAN.
ONE THAT'S THIRTEEN ZERO THE
BILLS OUT.
NUMBER FOUR SB FIFTY THREE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BEAU IS
FOURTEEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN [inaudible]
JONES.
HI LINDA FOR ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR SB FIFTY THREE WILK.
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN ZERO VOTE
[inaudible] FOR FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO WITHOUT IF THE
MEMBERS THAT THE I COULD PAY
ATTENTION AS WE CLOSE OUT THIS
THE A B. THE CHAIR WOULD BE.
GREATLY APPRECIATED --
MOVIE. FOURTEEN ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT.
FILE ITEM FIVE SB FIFTY EIGHT
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS VOTE IS
[inaudible]
TEN TO FOUR ABSENT MEMBERS
JONES [inaudible]
RUBIO.
YEAH CHIP.
OKAY THE BILLS OUT --
TEN FOUR ITEM NUMBER SIX THE SP.
ONE SIXTY NINE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTES.
THIRTEEN TO ONE ABSENT MEMBERS
JONES [inaudible]
AND RUBIO.
THE BILLS OUT.
THIRTEEN ONE HERE IN ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN IS ALREADY OUT THAT
CONCLUDES.
THE BILLS --
BEFORE THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE --
THIS MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED